foreign
hello everyone
welcome to this full course video on
HTML by simply learn this video will
help you understand all the concepts of
HTML and provide lots of Hands-On
example so let's discuss the agenda of
this tutorial
we started discussing what is HTML in 10
minutes then we will discuss HTML
classes and IDs and drop down HTML
after that we will discuss the content
boxes and HTML image slider
then we will see how I can create the
navigation bar registration form and
HTML quiz in HTML after all the learning
we'll design a fully functional website
using all the concepts that we have
learned we'll end with the web developer
roadmap and how you can achieve your
target of becoming a front-end web
developer
so let's begin
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the IP
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is so your browser starts by
loading the main HTML file and then the
CSS and JavaScript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the backend of an
application now secondly we have the
server once you've developed your
website you'll have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's IP address which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an IP address
we put a domain name over that IP
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is HTML HTML is the most
widely used markup language for
developing and structuring web pages on
the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is CSS then now CSS is a
simple design language used for making
web pages look more beautiful and
presentable
it can be attached to any HTML element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is Javascript
now JavaScript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development it
is used for making web pages interactive
and bringing the web pages to life
so now let's create your first website
now HTML short for hypertext markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs div
containers tables and more HTML tags are
nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags
so now let's write a simple HTML code
that will help you understand the basics
of the language so for this I am using
the text editor that is Visual Studio
code you can go ahead and download this
text editor from their official website
so here I've created a simple dot HTML
file in my vs code and I've added the
initial HTML files
now let me explain to you uh one by one
now doctype is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction now this
indicates the browser that the document
type to be served to the user is in fact
an HTML document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your HTML page next up you have the HTML
tag that is used to contain all the web
pages HTML code right so it contains an
opening and closing tag with contents in
between them
the HTML tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the Lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page followed by the HTML tag there's
the head tag now this is the first
section of the code that contains all of
the information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
Pages title description additional meta
tags and CSS code so here I've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
HTML
in 10 minutes
[Music]
all right you can also add CSS to the
Head tag by using the style tag and
change the display styles of HTML
elements that are being used the next
section is the body tag now the body tag
contains all the displayable contents of
your web page including headings
paragraphs div containers tables and
more
now the HTML header tags are used to add
headings to a web page there are several
types of headings available for
developers to add to a web page right so
first up let's have a look at them I'm
going to create a simple H1 heading tag
and the message I'm displaying is this
is
the first heading
all right
after this I'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so I'm gonna add a P tag and Save
this is the paragraph tag
[Music]
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading tag and say this is the
second heading
you can also add line breaks which are
helpful from time to time if you want to
provide a single line break in your
content you can do so by adding the BR
tag so here let me just add one for
better understanding now the HTML div
tag defines a division or a section in
an HTML document that is used as a
container for other HTML elements now
these elements can include content areas
sidebars page bars page headers Footers
Etc
this tag is used to apply styles to HTML
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the HTML image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a web page are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so say IMG
within which I mentioned the source
[Music]
adding the HTML logo so let me just
mention that here
and then I'm going to provide width for
it and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file and
when you look at the browser
you can see that the first heading is
displayed then your paragraph tag is
displayed followed by the second heading
and then the image now let me show you
how you can add styles for some of these
headings and paragraph tags so here in
back in my first heading tag let me just
say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
and I'm going to change it to Career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so I'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when I look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
HTML tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website in this tutorial we
are going to learn about the classes and
ID in the HTML and how to use them
so without further Ado let's get started
so what is an HTML class an HTML class
attribute is used to specify a single or
multiple class names for an HTML element
the class name can be used by CSS and
JavaScript to do some tasks for HTML
elements
you can also use this class in the CSS
with a specific class with a period
character followed by the name of the
class first selecting elements
so let's jump onto the demo to
understand the classes and ID better so
we are on a Sublime Text Trader
let's add the standard boilerplate of
HTML we'll give the title as classes
and ID in HTML
let's start with the basic example
we'll see how to define an HTML class
so inside the body tag
will add one H1
and we'll give this
the class name of
head1
we'll add some text here this is the
heading one
now you can copy this part because we'll
need it enough for the lines
so for the H2
this will be the heading 2
for H3
this will be heading 3.
and let's add one more H4
this is the heading 4.
so as you can see we have used the same
class name in all our H1 H2 S3 and S4
so if you save the file and
go to the page and refresh
you'll see the headings are there on the
page this is the heading one heading to
heading 3 and heading 4.
Google
now let's learn how we can use this
class name for our starting purpose
so we'll open the style tag here
and you will mention the class Name by
period followed by the class name so
head one
open the parenthesis
and let's set the color to
light sand
and we'll set the font family to set to
it cursive
keep the background color to Black
okay so you can see we have mentioned
the class name dot head one for our
styling purposes and we have given the
color of Point family and background
color for it so just save the file and
go back
refresh
now you can see we have designed this H1
H2 H3 and H4 using our class tag
now let's use another example with a
Different Cloth name
so here only we'll make the changes
let's name this class as H2 this H3 and
let it be H4
now you can style them separately for
the head to
we can set the color
to say light
pink and we can set the font background
color too
red okay
now
similarly for the H3
Dot
H3 set the color to
I don't know what color this is let's
say kuchisa
and set the background color to let's
say blue
okay save the file and go back to the
page
now you can see we have designed our H1
H2 H3 and H4 using the different class
name here's the example of using the
multiple classes on the same course
now one thing you should note that these
class name must be separated by the
space
there are few points you should know
while working with the class so the
first one will be the class attribute
can be used on any HTML element
like any HTML element can have a class
name the second point will be the class
name is a case sensitive
head one
and if we change here to say
we keep this Edge as kept Capital so
this will be wrong the style won't be
implemented on the page now if you
refresh you can see the style is not
implemented
so the class names are case sensitive
let's change this back
refresh and now you can see our design
is back
so this was all about HTML classes now
let's move on to the idea attribute
so the HTML ID attribute is used to
specify the unique ID for an element of
the HTML document
it allocates the unique identifier which
is used by the CSS and the JavaScript
for performing certain tasks
in cascading style sheet that is CSS we
mention an element with a specific ID by
using the hash symbol followed by the ID
let's work on an example to understand
this better
so we'll use the same previous example
we'll mention the H1 and this time we'll
use the ID
so ID and we'll name it as head 1.
this is the first heading
for H2 also
will mention the ID name as head one
only
head one
this is the
second heading
now to style The Heading we'll go back
here will open the style tab
and we'll use the hash chamber to
mention the ID so hash
head one open the parenthesis
dollar to
light green
we'll set the font family to cursive
and we'll set the background color
to Black
okay now save the file and go back and
refresh
so you can see this works a similar
manner to the class apart from it that
we use the hash symbol to mention the ID
name
so now let's change the example and use
the different ID name for different
hedge funds
so this can be H1 this can be H2
let's add one more we'll name it as ID
okay
so we'll style the
head to
we'll set the color to red
for head 3
foreign
let's use green yellow okay save the
file
go back and refresh
now you can see we have the different
style for different IDs so in this way
you can use the different IDs to design
your HTML page in this tutorial we are
going to learn how you can create a drop
down in your nav bars using this HTML
and CSS so vrmos Sublime Text Editor I
have the dot HTML and Dot CSS file ready
so let's start by adding the standard
boilerplate
let's give it a title
link your CSS file to the HTML file
now inside the body I'll add the uls
we have added this hash so that when you
click on this home button it won't
redirect you to anywhere
so just save the file
and we'll go back to our page
so you can see we have this home here
okay so let's add some more
so just copy paste this
and we'll name this section about
now inside this about I'll require some
sub menus
so inside this I'll open another UL tag
yeah
we'll add sections such as team
clients
career and Legacy
and we'll close the LI tag here
okay and save the file and go back here
and refresh
now we'll add some more so
here
we'll add the Ally for contact
okay so inside this contact I'll add the
sub menus
so you will
and I'll copy this code and I'll edit it
here
okay so inside the contacts I'll need
email
on
selected Twitter
and this will be my LinkedIn
okay
now we'll add some more sections
we'll name the services
and this one will be my news
okay
so this looks fine
little bit of alignment
yeah
so you can see we have this home about
contact services and news and inside
this we have the sub menus
okay we forget to add here hash inside
this message
just mention hash
everywhere
okay save the file
go back and refresh okay
so you can see we have this HTML ready
now let's go back to the CSS and design
these drop downs
so first Insider HTML
select the body tag
will add one background image so just
the background looks more attractive
so I have an image file save so I'll
jpg so save
go back and refresh
yeah you can see we have this black
thing uh we'll shrink this image
so we will keep the background size to
cover
foreign
family to aerial
okay
so for the UL tag
will keep the margin to zero
we'll keep the padding to zero as well
and we'll set the list style to none
okay now we will run the URL Li part
so we'll keep the float to left
width will set to 200 pixels
we will set the height to say 40 pixels
um we'll keep the background color
to something darker see
little dark gray okay
keep the opacity to 0.9
line height particles
thank you
keep the text aligned to Center
and font size two
20 pixels
save the file go back and refresh
okay you see we have the background
image in the place we have this snap
button place and all the drop downs are
here
okay
now it's time to design
UL
Li and a
so for this we'll keep the text
decoration to none
color like keep white
and we'll set the display to block
save the file and go back
now we'll add the horror effects for
this drop downs okay
so you will Ally
a DOT forward
we'll keep the background color
for the hoverboard to say
any clerical circuits let's write
calendar
save
let's see how it looks on the page
refresh
yeah it's look good
now the final part of this requires this
to shrink inside just let me hover over
this so the drop downs will appear
okay
so we'll set this UL Ali
Li 2 display none
and we'll add the whole effect over Li
so that when we hover the drop down
appears
save
go back and refresh now you can see all
the drop downs are inside this
when hover over it on the drop downs
appear
okay so this is all about a drop downs
menu in HTML as we saw that we can
create the beautiful drop downs just by
using the HTML and CSL nothing fancy
in this video we are going to create the
content boxes which are used in web
pages for various purposes
so let's see an example of what we are
going to create so in this video we are
going to create something like this this
is the content box with the icon and the
description of the content box
icons here used is from the font
awesome CDN
so let's start creating
so I have my two files open which is
HTML and CSS
let's add the standard boilerplate
we'll add the content
boxes in HTML
as the title
let's link our CSS file
now inside the body let's add a div
clock container
inside the disc plus container I'll
create another div box
I will require three such boxes so we'll
copy this this three times
on the time sheet
let's set the margin
to zero and padding also to zero
we'll set the font family
to
San serif
now for the container class
will set the position to relative
and we'll set the width to 1200 pixels
which is the whole width of the content
box
we'll set the height to 300 pixels
and we'll set the margin
to
240 pixels and Auto
for the boxes inside the container
will add the position
relative
and will set the width to
let me explain what this is
this CSS type function is used to
perform a calculation to be used as a
property value
this is specifically used for the width
of the div classes
it requires a mathematical expression
the result will be used as a value
so we'll be using lot of this type
function here in this code
we will set the height to
300 pixels minus 30 pixels
one property of cat function is that it
takes single expression as its parameter
the expression can be any simple
expression combining the following
operators
plus that is addition minus that is
subtraction multiplication and division
we'll set the background
to Hash zero zero zero
you will set it to float left
and we'll specify the margin to 15
pixels
and we'll set the Box sizing to border
box
overflow will be hidden
and Border radius
let's set it to 10 pixels
just save the file and let's go back to
the page to see how it currently looks
so you can see our boxes are in the
proper places we have the background
black with the proper margin between
them okay so we have the structure
let's code more
now we need the icon for that
will require
a icon from the font awesome
CDN so we'll add the font awesome CDM to
our page
so we'll search font awesome
CDN 4.7.0
we are using the older version because
it is more stable
so go to this font awesome
libraries
here select the version and copy the
link tag
go back to the page and add it here
delete this Integrity part
now
here inside this class box
add one div which will be named class
icon
and inside here we'll add the link of
the icon so search here
font awesome icon 4.7
go to the first one
here you can search the any icon you
want uh let me search for
see
information so I'll go to the
information
and I'll copy this
go back to the code and add it here
now inside this I'll create another div
which will be for use for content
so we'll name it class content
and inside this I'll add one H3
info
and inside it
I'll add some
text
copy this much from here
to here
and delete this whole part
and put it inside
do that
so inside the P tag
add them yeah
so let's go back to the file and see how
it looks right now
okay so you cannot see the icon here
because it is black let's try to change
the color here
so that you can see the icon
so let's set it to ff0
okay so you can see I have the icon in
place this is and this is the text that
we have added to this content box
now let's dial this content box first
set it back to zero zero zero
now
container dot box
dot icon
we'll set the position to Absolute
set the top
to zero
left to zero
and we'll set the width to 100 percent
you will set the height also to 100
percent
background will be hash f0000
will set the transition
to 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the Z index as one so
that the icon will be visible
okay
it is fresh yeah you can see the icon
here
okay
now let's add the whole effect on that
so container Dot
box dot over
we'll set that up to 20 pixels
and calculate the left two
fifty percent minus 40 pixels
with 80 pixels
height keep it to 80 pixels as well
and let's set the Border radius
okay
so now that we have repeat
so now that we have added the whole
effect let's save and go back to the
page
now let's design the icon so container
Dot
box dot icon
dot f a
okay
also set the position to Absolute
top will be 50 percent
left 50 percent
transform let's translate it to
minus 50 percent
um give the font size to
80 pixels
transition 0.5 seconds
and we'll set the color to
save the file and let's go back to the
page
yeah so you can see our icon has now
bigger size and with the hover effect it
shrinks for text to be visible
okay
now we need to add the hover effect to
the icon so that the font size increases
for that we'll add container
box dot over
and we keep the font size to
40 pixels
okay
now it's time to design the content
inside the container box so we'll set
container
dot box
dot content
all the positions are absolute
we'll set the top 200 percent
so that run the icon shrinks the whole
text will be visible to the text box
we'll set the height
2 will calculate it
100 percent
minus 100 pixels
text align Center
keep the padding to 20 pixels
for proper spacing
box sizing as border box
transition to 0 0.5 seconds
and will keep the opacity to zero
okay save the file and let's go back
yeah now you can see the icons are in
the center of the shrinking Circle
now let's add the hover effect
now when you set the opacity to one
another text
okay we are not
designed yet S3 and P so let's start
designing it
so container
dot box
dot content H3
indexes
keep the padding to zero
color
and let's keep the font size to 24
pixels
now you'll see the text will be visible
Inside the Box
so refresh
yeah you can see this is the heading of
our this content box info
now similarly let's style the paragraph
tag
so container
dot box
dot content
e
margin will be zero
padding will be also zero
and color will be FFF as usual
if
yup we are almost there
now we will Design these two boxes with
some spacing and effects over here
now
uh inside this
delete them we'll copycase the above
code here
so copy from here leave class container
will change the icon classes here so for
this let's keep search as a r c h
instead of copying the class by going
back to the font ctm you can directly
add the class search here if you know
the name of the class
and here we can add
location
so the class name for location is map
marker
save the file
and let's go back
yeah now you can see
these things are here
the good content box when you hover over
this box so
this whole thing shrinks and you can see
the text visible
now add We'll add some Styles we'll
change the color and we'll add one
background here so that when this
shrinks the background color of the
black changes
okay
so we'll go back to our code
so to clean the color of the box
will add a DOT container
dot box
and we'll use the nth child property the
nth child
one because the first box
dot icon
so we'll keep its background too
think
okay
and Dot container
box and child
one its color will be when it shrinks
let's keep it to Orange
yeah
so save the file
go back
and refresh
okay so you can see we have the icons in
places and when you go
click on here set the hover effect
shrinks this and this is the pink in
color we have the background orange with
some text here
you can see
smooth transitions
so this is all for the content boxes in
HTML you can use different icons here
using this font at awesome icon there
are several icons here you can use any
of them and just make sure that the
padding and the text are aligned in the
proper places in this video we will
learn how you can create a beautiful
HTML slider by using just HTML and PSS a
little bit of JavaScript
look something like this you have the
background image and there's images that
I have taken for example purpose you
have this video button and you click on
the radio buttons we can go through our
images one by one
also the images will change
automatically after some times as you
can see
so how you can create this in a slider
so here in the desktop I have created
one file where I have the required
images
and HTML and CSS file
so first in the storm side let's add our
radio buttons
from treatment
and limited edition slider
in fact I'll create another
which will name the big class slides
inside the ZIP code We'll add the radio
buttons so input
the input tab will be radio
and let's give this name
radio button
and we'll tag them with ID radio 1.
so as you can see
potential so we'll add radio buttons
here
so just copy paste this four times
foreign
slide first
inside I'll create an image tag
and special part of the event
in a similar we create a few div tags
for four images
so just we'll do certainly another term
with class name
slide
inside this image
Google Dot jpj
so just save the file and let's view
check our code
we have the relay buttons we have the
images so let's just go back to our file
and see how it looks
so it will refresh
and some distorted images
and let us fix this images in the CSS
so instead of USS file
will add the body
and we'll set the margin to zero pixels
we'll set the height to say 100 vertical
height
will set the display to flex
uh we'll just Define the content to
Center
we'll set the Align items to Center
and we set the background to Black
so just
refresh this file
so it's time to fix these images
so just
set the slider width to
800 pixels
okay there's an error we'll say this
breadth not Windows
we had the height to 500 Degrees
at the border radius
to 10 pixels
and overflow will keep as hidden
for the slice part
will set the width to 500 percent
High to 500 pixels
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so yeah you can see the images now in a
proper size you have to click this video
button we have the background black
so let's existence
so for the slide input
okay before starting with let's add
common HTML content here
so image we have to create the automatic
navigation button and the manual
navigation button
so after this
has another day
the class name
navigation Auto let's see
and inside this navigation Auto will add
Dev
class
or to button one
we need the code button so we'll copy it
four times
and this will be my button two
this will be button free and this will
be button 4.
outside this they will create another
visible for the manual navigation button
so we'll name this
navigation
make sure it's qualified and then we
communication
manual
and inside this
but we'll add our radio buttons usually
manual
the limit class manual button m-e-n-e
we need the code button so we will copy
it four times
we change the label to Radio 2
radio 3 and radio 4.
so I think this will work enough so here
we have the navigation
okay we have a spell mistake here
classroom
foreign
so let's see if the file and go back and
refresh it and see how it looks
okay
you have to add some CSS here
so inside the slides
input
reported this clear to learn
foreign
to 800 pixels
and we'll set the height to say 500
pixels
okay let's save the file and let's go
back to see how it looks right now
okay so you can see the images are
properly aligned here
now we have to style our radio buttons
for here so let's go back to our CSS
now the code we are going to write here
move for the manual slide navigation
so just add here comment manual line and
application
foreign
will set the position to Absolute
then set up it to 800 pixels
will not have a height here will set the
margin
probability
minus qualifications
and this we will keep it as black
and the justify content
will be sent out
so let's go a and go back to the page to
see how it looks right now
okay the images are in the center you
can see
now you cannot see our radio buttons
just as now we have to add some color to
it so that the Innovations will be
visible
so go back to the CSS
we'll add the manual button
we'll set the Border
to save three pixels
solid and red
you can put any color you want
we'll set the padding to 5 pixels
uh we'll set the Border radius to say
nine pixels
we set the processor to point pointer so
that whenever buttons the Consular route
has a pointer
and we'll set the transition to one
seconds
say
go back and refresh
so now you can see the buttons are here
not properly spaced but yeah they are
here
so let's add the spacing and everything
else
so we'll take the manual button
will set the margin
right through particles
and it's time to add the over effect so
for the manual
button
the Google will be
um say background
hello
just save the file and go back and
refresh
yeah so you can see our manual buttons
are in place
when you hover over it you can see the
blue head and when you click
nothing happens right now because we
don't have any JavaScript response to
this data button We'll add them in the
end
first let's design these buttons so this
was for the manual button
now we'll add one code which will be
used when we want to select the radio
button by default
so let's understand how this video
buttons work in this
files we have two or no options are
identified which are usually exclusive
and the user has to evacue one choice
previously
keep all the options visible said that
users can easily analyze them
to use for users who have difficulty in
making effective mass movements
so we'll add hash video
dot check
so the sign that we have added here is
more sibling combinator
immediately after the first
so we'll add DOT first
and for this we'll set the margin left
to zero
okay so this will be radio 1.
the label that we added in our manual
buttons
will need for such
buttons so we'll copy this four times
one one two three and four
this will be my for radio button 2.
and we'll set the margin left here to
minus 20 pixels
okay
minus 40 pixels
for me to add decision
and for the last button we'll set it to
minus 15 pixels
so all the stories for the manual
navigation button now let's design for
automatic navigation button
so we'll open Dot navigation
we'll set the position to Absolute
will set the display to flat
we'll set the width
to 800 pixels
uh let's justify the content in Center
and put the margin top
60 pixels
now
so I'll add the file to navigation or
Twitter
so
navigation
until
then set the Border
to same model that we have used here
it will shape it's a solid red
thank you
make sure you keep this secret so
soluted and same in both the navigation
Auto and navigation manual because if
you change the color here you will see
the two manual buttons there so for just
example let's change this to Green
so when it's save and go back
and refresh
yeah
you can see the two button here this is
it green and this is red so if there are
two colors the motor buttons will
overlap will not feel good so we'll just
keep it here red
we'll set the padding to five pictures
we'll set the Border radius to 9 pixels
and we'll set the transition to 1
seconds
you know
same code AS here which I added for
checking on the radio buttons
so we'll just copy this whole curve
and paste it here
we will
so the class was navigation dot Auto
so we'll add here
navigation or Pro
so
Auto button one
this is some background
so we'll delete this code
um
okay
background let's say
any color pink
copy this code Ctrl C
delete this whole thing Ctrl U
H and just change the radio button there
this will be radio button
this will be three
and this will be formed
now we have all the designing in place
now we have already designing in place
let's go back to the code and refresh
so now you'll see everything is good the
background is that that the images is
properly aligned we have this button so
let's click
so when you click you see the images
slides this is a photo mesh okay
second
and first so if it is ready all that now
is left is to add the JavaScript code to
this image character function in
automatic manner
so now we'll go back to this HTML file
and below this div tag
will open once click tab
inside this flip tag
we create one
variable name counter
set it to one
open we create one function set interval
foreign
so what we thought specifically does is
we have created one variable named
counter and it will check against the ID
that we have created a radio then the
radio button says checked and it
encounters
the counter will be plus plus that
automatically increase by one
so after the counter has reached to flow
so it will get back to the starting
point that is one so the whole point of
this code is to
make the images slide in you know so
just save
and go back
now when you refresh
you see the images we move after
sometimes
specifically two seconds
now when the images become last page it
goes back to the first
you can also change it I can
manually when we talk about external
based development so in HTML based
development navigation is very important
where you have called multiple Pages
attached to so that when you click on
this page or click on any hyperlink it
will take you to the new page now so
that you can move back and forth so this
navigation is very essential part of any
web development so that you can offer
the navigation so this simple
application of HTML we would like to
start from scratch so let's go and
create a new folder now and give the
name called navigation
and inside this navigation we want to
create some new pages so
here I'm going to create index
dot HTML
the CSS name will be app dot CSS and
along with this we would like to also
create some new folder inside this I'll
keep all the navigation files inside
this so I can save pages
inside this Pages let me have total
number of three pages with me when it's
called about
dot HTML
then we create
contact
dot HTML
then we create one more that is called
services.html
dot HTML so these three links we will
create it one by one but first let's
start with the index.html so what's
there in my index.html file so first
thing I would like to start with my same
HTML syntax here
well this is my basic construct
so I will start with my link Ariel from
here so that I can have my Starship with
me link audio equal to stylesheet href
equal to app Dot see it says no I have
not written anything but I just left it
as a blank in my body tag I would start
with the navigation so HTML5 brought you
some new tags no one is called a nav tag
which is once again
won't change anything drastically in
your browser however they are called
cementex which will help you for the SEO
that stands for search engine
optimizations I'll start with my nav
inside my nav I will start with my div
I'll say navigation bar so but before
that I say
class equal to
headache
this is my Dev tag and inside my tip tag
I want to bring my heading so I say H4
and I said
navigation bar
and offer the div tag I'll start with my
UL tag which is an unordered list inside
my
list items and I can offer lot many
links inside this so you will I just
offer the class
equal to
nav hyphen
let's
and inside is my array tag I said okay
which is the anchor tag
so
a link href equal to
now here I offer
the name I say index
Dot ht1 and that's it and this will be
by default active so we say plus equal
to
vector
okay
class equal to it active and HR equal to
index.html file and here we have a home
for home page I'll copy this line
and paste it for other three urls
so
here
the active won't be there instead we say
httf equal to
location called pages
onto these pages we say about
about.html and here we say about
okay copy this
paste it
and all of this about we always say
for resist.html and here we say
services
inside this we offer
contact
okay and once the lab tag is over
I will offer the tip
Plus
text
I just say H1 tag inside this
and this is the home page
that's it so that's my home page which
is ready with me
and along with this whichever the other
pages are also available
those pages I also want to use so first
of all let me check how this page looks
like it
well it looks like a very basic page so
all this page is ready what I will do is
here I copy the content
and paste it here and above and let's
see what's there in my above see few
things will change number one here
this app dots USS
now here we have to just use
dot dot
there's an approach uses for me
so you have to offer some title too so
after this link are you
awful
title this title I can say
okay
so rest everything is fine
so H4 navigation bar enablings here I
have to offer the links for my previous
HTML page so when I talk about
index.html file
foreign
so I won't say it is an active anymore I
just remove this line
plus equal to X that's just an normal
hrf but about would be active in this
case so
okay
class equal to
active instead of this
Services contact
because as usual thing but I would not
be having any
Pages anymore
because we are in the same location
that's why and here I say this is a
about this is about page
about page
so that's it
I'll go back and check
if it are fine
home is active right now about you can
see it as an above page right now about
page is just appeared as it is saying
contents are more or less looks like and
same that is why you are able to see
now just like that
I will just go back and copy the others
now here I have CSS navigation bar
active
it is in contacts or make contact as an
actor
so indexual file it will make the same
this is
contact page
so
that's how it is and we will say about
my other properties which is my
Services let me copy sorry
copy this contact
and here
I'll be activating my
service in this case so
class equal to active I remove it from
here
make it available here this is
service page navigation index pages
about active yeah or looks good heading
about over here I change
service
it is a change to
looks fine
let's see
okay
service contact about
so for about we need to check where we
need to go
so we have got pages
about dot HTML page is also there
so
all there so we would like to see how
the about page will be activated here so
index.html file also contains an about
so here
when I
refresh
well
you never call
index.ht Page
talk vocal about
where these are about page now
services
so like this it is happening for you
okay so that's how exactly my thing is
so we're all good
and uh
Services contact home all good well my
page is now ready and going forward we
would like to beautify my Pages by
offering the CSS well let's get started
with our CSS file so in my CSS file I
will start with my
common properties
which is margin
I'm saying 0 pixel
followed by adding
I'm making a zero pixel again
we want box sizing
thus I say border
hyphen box
okay well going forward this is my
standard settings for all different type
of properties now I want the other
properties to be getting introduced that
is for box body text
Dot
body
iPhone
text
inside is body text I said display
Flex
now what I see where the body text is
available go into my index.html file
body text is available here div class so
here in my CSS file I can say body text
display flex and I say font family
font family I can give anything
it is giving God Bond save it
sensory
these two
we are offering it later on align items
NL item Center
followed by justify content
we're making a center
then margin top
pixels
these are the properties out there
followed by
okay first let's check what is an effect
here
see it looks better now
if you would like to go into the nav I
already have the snap with me
now
let's play
Flex
then justify content
space around
followed by align item
align items I want to make Center
and then we want to say mid height
so we say when hyphen
okay so midnight we are giving a3h
followed by background color
foreign
family you just copy this form currently
and make it available here well let's
check
there we go so nav bar looks awesome but
I still feel the links needs to be
justified we want to make it even more
better but before that I offer the nav
links so here I see
nav links so dot nav
hyphen lens
this nav lens will have display
Flex
display
flex and then justify content
that I want to make it space around
again
followed by width
so
width so width would be 20 percent
perfect and now nav link Li Dot
enablings
Li
this
Style
no
let's see how it is changing
there we go that it looks really nice so
nablings are ready and I want to make it
a heading heading
I want to make it more organized so
let's see about a heading
so here I say dot
cutting and inside this heading I say
color
which is white
followed by text
transform
text text transform Upper Keys
followed by letter spacing
this letter spacing will be 5 pixels
and followed by last font size
and the font size is just 20 pixel
that's it and let's see how it is
different see
here awesome so this navigation bar is
now looking great and it is giving me
all the basic operation whichever we
have expected now this nav link
whichever we have created okay they are
working fine but I just want to make it
even more beautiful
and how I can make it more beautiful to
make it I would like to go ahead with
the nav links again
Dot
nav links off type anchor tag
now I would like to activate my anchor
type by making it color
White
okay followed by text decoration
text decoration now
and followed by letter spacing
let us pressing three pixels
and then font weight
font weight bold
and font size
14 pixels
and padding
and 16 pixels
both options
that's it and followed by we want to use
the nav licks when I will hover it so
the color should change so we are saying
Dot nav links
and here with li
followed by a DOT
active when the anchor tag is active
then in that case I want to change the
backing color
to Lights light C green I can say
lights
so
we have this option called light C green
this one right signal that looks
beautiful and followed by same
I'll copy this
and this active so nav links I like DOT
active background color we are using but
if it is not active then in that case
what you will use
so I can just change the small thing
here
I've changed this color
uh now let me try to copy this first I
tell you what I want
to copy this and I paste it as usual
here what I see is when it is an active
I will change the color to
I think the spelling is wrong active it
should be
active background color I want to change
this to Green so for that we are just
using the color hash
this is a green color
when it is an active and when this is
not active
so we can just say a colon
active
which is used now now l i colon active
or we can say equal whole
equal
over
a colon over and here we say column not
Dot
active that's it
let's see how it works
awesome this looks beautiful home home
is an active right now they say it is on
a home page I can see it is an about
page
it is service page it is a contact now
you can see it looks even more awesome
in this HTML page and so on we are
expecting that all of you are aware
about the basic concept of HTML as well
as the CSS so this
kind of learning is going to help you to
understand like how HTML and CSS can
connect together while offering you a
mini application the first application
on this track we're going to offer you
that is related to your HTML
registration page okay so as you know
for this particular registration
development application I would like to
use the visual studio code which is one
of the very very popular tool provided
by Microsoft so this tool we will be
using it for our mini application
development so let's get started with
this so step number one let me go back
and create a new folder now I will
create a new folder name called
registration
and inside this I would require two
files number one is called index dot
HTML
and another one that is called
CSS we can say app dot CSS so in
index.html file we want some started
development so I want to start with my
HTML tag so
I already have this HTML based autofill
code provided by your Visual Studio code
so there are plugins are available
inside this so that you can
automatically create the basic structure
for this HTML which you can have the
HTML tag head tag as well as the body
tag and from this point onwards we will
start developing our code now so I want
to develop a registration page so in
this registration page I will start from
my form tag now so inside this form it
is saying like form action to something
I really do not have any backend so I
just leave it as a blank and here I will
start with my H1 tag then I want to say
register
after this register I want to offer the
paragraph tag
where I can say please
fill
in this
form
two
register with this
register
okay now after that I would like to
start with horizontal row so HR
so
starting with my horizontal row
and pause this because we would like to
organize our application and now
level at this level for I just want to
give the name called FF it's just the
name and after this FN stands for the
first name and within this label I would
like to use a b type which is a I would
say the Bold terrible pass fasting
bull attack is close it's a level
inside this level I would like to use
input tag we have a call input app equal
to text and offer few other details also
like I say a placeholder
place order will offer you what to be
free I'm saying first name
that is
the placeholder value after this name
equal to FN that is the stand for first
name after that id id is optional but if
you want to pass we'll use this idfn
is equal to f n and required
because I want this field cannot be
black so this is my
first text box where I have this
first name with me
like that I will go ahead and talk about
my next property called password and for
password also I would like to have the
similar details with me
so this level I'll copy
and paste it below
and this is for
your password so we give the name called
PSW
here we are saying password
and input typical text so here I will
change input app equal to password
it is password field details would not
be visible to you please here say
placeholder I can say enter
password
name equal to
you can give PSW
password in a similar like we would like
to offer a confirm password fields too I
will copy this slide
and paste it again and here we can say
confirm password
you can see
cpsw again password enter
confirm password cpsw
and cpsw
now it's over after this we want to make
it as a horizontal row
closed
and once it is run then we'd like to
have the button with this
here's the button we can say register
and here in my button I would like to
offer the type equal to submit
are we going to submit so that's it so
this is the simplest form I have it
now I would like to see how it really
looks like it so from here I would like
to open it Rebellion finder
let's open this
well it looks like that
fine so this is what makes formal form
is ready and now we would like to go
back and start developing my CSS in
which I will beautify my form to offer
some more details on this
well friends as we know the HTML page is
ready it's time to go back and start
developing a CSS to beautify my HTML so
inside the CSS I would like to start
with the tag which is a call body
and inside this body tag I can offer
some basic setups but
I just want to give the basic background
color now which is called
background hyphen color I can just give
the name for tea
the rest of the things I can just leave
it as it is now for all the other
properties I can say box sizing
go to iPhone box
after that
dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits now first thing you
need to understand which are the places
I will be using the container
see here in my index.html file
when we talk about form actions in and
all okay we say H1 register we haven't
used any container right now so let's
get added the container
do
class equal to
container
okay and this particular div tag will
get closed only at the last
so the strip tag
you close at the last
here so I want to make the look and feed
for this complete container in much more
better way so here in my container we
want to see
margin Auto
press enter here
margin
Auto now with
50 percent
then adding
fixing pixel
followed by background color
if you want white
then box shadow
this box Shadow we want to give some all
four Origins 20 pixel you
know
continuation to save 20 pixel
and zero pixel
and which color we want if I just say
RGB here
this rgba just give the value called
zero
again zero
and the value which you would want to
give to this Alpha because it is always
between 0 to 1 we are saying 0.7 that is
an opacity
well four properties is given now let's
see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a CSS
in my HTML so let's add the CSS so
inside my
browser HTML
now inside my head let me add link
href equal to
app dots uses
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now so this is
your container okay which you can see it
is having some Shadow I would like to
organize this all set of text boxes in
much more better way
so after this
we want to offer the other properties
too like informal input
go back to my xcss
so after this container we want input
input again
time equal to
text
now also
to
input
type
equal to
password
here we offer few things number one
width
which is hundred percent
after
sorry
then padding
one second 15 pixels
then margin
you're offering 5 pixels
zero
22 pixel
followed by display
I will say inline block
inline block followed by border do you
want any border
so I say none
and background
we can offer the color so we can say
right smoke
that's it let's see in my HTML
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized so this is
your form but I want to make it even
more better now because I want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the beautification needs to be
added more here we want to offer the
same input type text input type password
I copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
Focus
this has to be your focus
focus and here also on Focus
now background color
we want to change to anything but other
typing we can just give
it same and outline
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button so here we say dot
I do not have that class called register
button so I have to create this class
inside my
button
resistor BTN I would like to offer the
properties for those like background
color
foreign
followed by color
which is
White
then padding
we offer 16 pixels
then border
no
then cursor
I think it is better to have pointer
only
than width
hundred percent
solved by margin
then opacity
and I say 0.8
fine so this is for my registration
button let's see
wow this looks better now so this is a
full size button
so this is for my button and I want the
moment I take my cursor on button
the color should change or it should
look like it hover
copy this
foreign
and here we say opacity
which is with the logical one that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this you see how the
conditions are working on Express on
register you see the messages
please fill the field blank and it is
changing
the
when we talk about the situation called
Focus so in this it works like that when
I give the name
you see now how the background color is
changing now so it is little bit more
grayish color so this time we're going
to develop another very interesting
example using this HTML JavaScript and
CSS together and that is called working
with a quiz application so one of the
very very interesting projects we'll be
developing it from the scratcher I'm
sure that you will enjoy a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all I'm gonna
give the name call
HTML quiz
now I'm going to create a three files
inside this number one I'm gonna say
index.html
index.html then I need another file that
is called app.css
and the third file I'm going to create
an inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
torches
so we have total number of three files
ready with us now from HTML page we
would like to develop this HTML tags
first
so we'll go to the HTML and see
so we have got this basic HTML syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards Dev tag
so visit my tab tag we would like to
create another div tag
okay so the first top level class
to this particular table see we haven't
created a CSS but we would like to offer
some of the CSS classes available here
so you see the plus equal to container
now we have got another Dev track inside
this we will say tab
ID
equal to question i1 container
question iPhone
container so that is the name or ID of
this step and we say class
equal to height
now within the step tag we would like to
offer some details
but before that we would like to create
some embedded Dev tags inside this so
we're going to create another Dev tag
here
and this step ID
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's ID name and we would like to
offer the class also
class equal to
BTN hyphen grid see again I'm telling
you these classes we're just creating it
but we would like to use this in our CSS
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now insert this div tag
if you want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one I would like to offer few buttons
now
button so we see a button class
equal to BTN
and after that you would like to give
the name call answer one
answer worth so that I can have this
button class
copied three more times
okay
and now we can change the names to
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us Dev tag is
getting closed here other tip tag is
getting closed here and now here before
the last tip track is getting close we
would like to create another div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's in the Deep tag so under this tip
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button ID equal to
start button
start iPhone BTN
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
ptn space BTN
and we say start here
now just copy this complete line
and put it again
so rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
next iPhone button BTN and we will give
additional property called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this S capital
and
two buttons we have created
after this Dev tag is getting closed
after that I would like to start another
tech tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with this
plan
and here we will say span ID equal to
right high five
answer
or answers I can see
so after that a div tag is getting
closed
and that's it and it lasts the last step
tag is getting closed
which you can see it right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this deep tag I would like to close even
before
two tip tags are getting close and this
is another tip type which is closed at
the end and here we want to include the
script tag
a script
SRC equal to
script.js that's it our HTML page is
almost ready Let's review
and
yes I can see some standard buttons has
been created now we would like to look
make gives a better look and feel to
this kind of Button cell complete UI by
offering some awesome CSS
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with CSS part now
so to work with the CSS we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a root and which has
wrote some basic settings we are
offering it number one
hyper hyphen Hue hyphen neutral
few
hyphen
hyphen hyphen hue
hyphen neutral the value given is equal
to 200.
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen hue
again hyphen wrong
this value we're giving is
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hue
this we are making with a variable
how can I find you neutral the one which
we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving 0
next property is margin
module also remains zero after that
display
none
after that not display I would say none
instead it is better we can have
Flex
after that width
we're providing width almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again 100
okay now we have called justify contents
let's justify Contents I can say Center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say Center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
in this we will like to use this VAR
again this in this world we are using
iPhone hyphen Q
and followed by
100 percent
comma 20 percent
these things and this is style we're
going to we would like to use in my
index.html page So within my head tag
well in index.html5 how you would like
to define the Styles we always use
link
CSS so the value is automatically
styled.csl but we would like to change
to app
s.css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting now we want
to offer few more things into my CSS it
is only for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body Dot
correct
body dot correct
we are providing
hue
over
and here you would like to offer
iPhone now
and also sorry not wrong just hold
correct
and we could use
body
dot Raw
body.com
so same thing I'd like to copy
so rather than saying correct
we're using rocks
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working with a container
container inside my container I would
like to offer with
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by Maxwell
this Max would be 80 percent
now going forward background color
background color we are offering White
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box should be canceled zero
zero
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used right
over here let's see
okay now it looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container now we would like to offer the
buttons
here in our CSS
we want to now offer the button colors
so dot
BTN
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file so we have a call
Button grid this button grid we would
like to start from here
between grid between grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying to
comma
Auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this Gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then zero
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now going forward we would like to apply
the styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in well
button grids we have created it now we
would like to go ahead with the buttons
so dot ptn
followed by the details so
foreign
will be using neutral
what's going forward we would like to
use border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or I would say one pixel
and install it
and hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
War
hyphen icon View
followed by
100 percent
30 percent
okay so these are the values for border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so in background color we will just use
hsl rather than this
so high point Hue 100 and 50 percent
okay
followed by border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding just 5 pixels
and 10 pixels
then color
this color will be white for sure
and the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor will be using pointer as you
should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button hover
Dot vtn
Dot or
and for this pull forward
you want to say border color
less border color you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well so
this is how my
initial looks like it
okay now I also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here we want to use Dot
start hyphen BTN
and also for
Dot
next hyphen PT
common look and feel for both font size
one
dot five
next font weight
now this won't wait I want to keep bold
followed by padding
this padding is B with 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with control switch it display
s
followed by justify contents
let's justify content service center
followed by align
items
and here we say Center
and last option which is left is called
height
let's hide you say
display none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be visible to me
so the moment I said start then with
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is well my CSS is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now this is a major part of
your main code development so here we
will start working with this const and
here we will say start
button equal to
document Dot
get element by ID and here you will give
the name call
start iPhone ptn
that's the name like this
I just copy this line
make it available here like we will call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
foreign
click here another one
here we change the name and give the
name call question
container element
container
element
question container element documented
element by ID
here we give the name called question
hyper container
question iPhone
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there we're using question
hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called question element
question
element document record element by ID
here will be passing
question
followed by
foreign
we want to use answer button element
answer buttons element
answers
or I can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called Shuffle question because
we want every time the questions to be
get shuffled
shuffled questions
Shuffle questions
current question index
Shuffle questions and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable called let
quiz score
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
ant questions
equal to
array first question which I would like
to create it here is called question
now here we will say
JavaScript framework
so which of these is a
which one of these I would say which one
of these is a JavaScript framework
here's my question now
okay so I would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer I
can say
like this
here I see text
first would be python
python
okay python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here I say
Django
correct false third is react
so
here I can say true
last I'm keeping it score
false as you should see
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so here after that we want to create few
more
okay so once again I would like to bring
some questions now
and related answers
so I just copy this
first
so second question
I can say
who is the prime minister of India
foreign
answers available
okay
talk about converter Modi value is
called for true
second we're going to give the name call
the value is called false
so I've taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 multiplied by
3.
I can have many answers
so I'm just making the first is called
six
it's false seconds turn
like that total we have created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay now once it is done we would like
to offer one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be known scroll clear
status class
function
here
status
Plus
it takes some parametrical element
and here we will say element Dot
class list
Dot
remove
element dot class list dot remove
correct
and once again I copy the same line
foreign
[Music]
so we have two options available
right convert wrong
now going forward we want to have few
more functions to be attached there is
only one function we've attached that's
called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
called function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it now
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which you have created
pass element
forward drive you're saying if
correct
then
element
Dot
classlist Dot
add
correct
okay
else
use the same option
what we will try to add from here
so this is how we would like to apply
it or wrong
so this is set status class which we
have it now followed by the most
important function which you're going to
use it right now here is called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we'll pass e is in parameter
and from here we will reuse const
select selected button
selected button equal to e Dot
Target
number one second const
ant correct
equal to
selected button
Dot
data set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this set status class
function
in this set status class we'll be
passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and correct
is the second parameter
okay now we are using
array Dot from
and here's this editor from we are using
answers
button element
Dot
children
okay followed by Dot
for each here
we're using this button
is in parameter
now here what I will do here using this
option called search status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button Dot
data set Dot
we can give the value called what
correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array now we'll be utilizing the main
evaluated value equal if
so for question Dot length
if Shuffle questions dot length is
greater than
current quotient index
Plus 1.
then what
then we are saying
next button
Dot
classlist Dot
remove
and here you will say height so this
will be hidden
okay else
condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot in a text equal to
restart
okay and next is called start button
Dot
classlist Dot
remove what we need to remove hide part
that's it
okay and here we are using this option
called if
selected button Dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document Dot
get a limit by ID
here we are providing
right iPhone
answers
followed by
Dot
inner HTML equal to
quiz let's score
so whatever this code will be after
selecting the correct answer this will
be available to the user
okay now the next thing which we're
going to develop it is basically your
reset state
function reset state
foreign
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
Dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
Dot
classlist dot add
height
okay now
we are using this while option now
answers put an element
DOT first child
so here I will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call Dot remove child and
here we'll be giving
assets button elements
Dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now we haven't called those
functions but we'll be calling those
functions one by one
but this is something which you wanted
to start with
okay
well reset state is already set now
going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
the first parameter will be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the questionary mode
so we have a call question element Dot
in a text
equal to
question Dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question Dot
answers
plot
for each and here I would like to use
we are passing what
answer as a parameter
now here we like to create a button
called const
button
document Dot
get sorry document.create element
create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot in a text
you have to set the value equal to
answer
Dot
text
Then followed by button Dot
classlist Dot
add here we are
offering
video
okay now you're saying if
the condition is
answer Dot
correct
if answer is correct then what then
button
Dot
dataset Dot
correct equal to
answer Dot
correct
okay now
the next thing is we are using button
dot add event listener attaching The
Listener to this event which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer whatever element
Dot
app engine of what
button so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set next question
next question
oh
function set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset State the function we are calling
it and saying
show question
and here we are passing this
Shuffle questions
and we are passing this current question
in text that is what is set
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
foreign
questions equal to
we have got questions Dot
sort
okay here we say
math Dot
random
and
five
we're passing this value
okay after that we are saying
current question index initially we are
giving 0 right now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
Dot
classlist Dot
remove
height
okay and then
calling
set next question
which is the function we are calling it
by initializing our quiz score
that the value equals zero
well start game is
ready next thing which you have to start
the cover part
so here we are saying
start button
Dot
add event listener
here in this
on my click event
I will try to call this function
start okay
first thing now next we'll be calling
next button Dot
add event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
question index
current course question index plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so here are mostly done with our code
script.js We have basically already
initialized there
okay so the values will be kept
automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
Okay so
our JavaScript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with us now let's finally see
how my overall local field really looks
like it just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome I could see the first
question appears automatically which of
these are JavaScript framework if I
select as using my correct answers for
react
now you can see is automatically making
rest of them as a red and or giving me
the next button now
who's the Prime Minister of India and
Signal Modi great next and I say
4 multiplied by 3 is at 12 I say next
and which of those used in mobile app
development flutter and flask as a flask
it says Twitter and now you can see the
application looks perfectly fine and it
gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how dear
friends your project is now completely
working and expected as a way it was
designed for when I once I can restart
and you can say start button now it's
giving me 4 multiply by 3 that means it
is one second I have taken random
question this mini project will help you
to understand how we can align our
content to display to my end user so lot
many things are there we have a code CSS
in place we have a HTML in place and
using some css3 based effects using some
HTML5 based effects we will be creating
our mini website having some single HTML
page and a CSS and lot of images will
help you to understand in case if I want
to develop a website how to Kickstart
them okay so let's get started so this
is my folder I've created called Web Pro
and in a similar folder I'll be creating
some of the files so my first file will
be called styles
dot CSS so in this files.c so first of
all I need to import some of the fonts
which I will be using it throughout my
development so I'm saying to add the
rate
import URL and here I'll be offering the
location by saying
https
songs
Dot
Google
apis
.com
CSS
okay question mark we have to use family
equal to here we can use Allura
and with using this pipe symbol we are
using josphere
chose field plus cents
so that is the URL for me in case if you
want to verify whether this URL does
exist or not so what you can do you can
just copy this
go to your browser and try to paste this
and check if it does exist yes it does
exist that means this URLs are available
to us so this is a URL which I'll be
using it for my development after that
I'll be using this is astric and
providing some of the core features like
a margin
colon zero
followed by other details okay like I'm
saying margin colon 0 and
padding once again zero followed by box
sizing
it is pressing bottom box
followed by outline
okay none
okay and pause this we'll be offering
this style
here we are also seeing none
after that text decoration
text decoration once again
none
after that font family
so we are using this
this option which you think called
josphere
okay sorry this double which we have
used
comma
we're using one more called sense
iPhone 7.
so this would be a first set of the
style which will be Global to all I'll
be using this
well earlier we have given the common
style to all now I'll be giving a start
to my paragraphs so
here in my paragraph we are trying to
say margin
hyphenate
in Bottom I want to give all 15 pixels
because I want to develop all this
rights well in advance before I proceed
ahead we are saying font I Recon size
yeah font type and size that we want to
give it for 14 pixels
followed by line height
line height I'll give 20 pixels
after that color
you can give anything
okay so there's one very common color
called light blue
for that there's only value called five
f
okay 8e
8 e
and again 8 e
we can see that is called a kind of
light green color which is coming up now
okay which is used now a part of this
paragraph we'll be using H1 title
okay assured title that in this H1 title
we are saying margin bottom
margin bottom we are saying 20 pixels
after that color
Orange
okay uh let me put semicolon here
along with this phone family
this fonts I will be giving Allura
okay along with this we also want to
give purism
curation
okay also text
transform
this text Transformer I want to use
uppercase
along with this font size
this font size I would like to give 38
pixels
followed by font size
yeah so this font size I want to give is
called 38 pixels
oh one said we've already given a word
spacing we have to give
this word spacing within 25 pixels
qualifying letter spacing
uh relatively simple between five pixels
so these are the details we have given
for the
H1 title
okay so now we'll be talking about our
buttons which are the relation field we
have to go or provide to our button so
we are saying once again
[Music]
width
1 80 pixels
on second
here with 180 pixels we're giving height
25 pixels
for it by line height
line height we're giving 35 pixels
followed by border
this border will be 2 pixels
solid
black
okay after that color
color we want to give it I would say red
would be sufficient enough
followed by display
I want to give it a score block
followed by margin
margin I'm going to give 25 pixels
Auto
and zero
followed by text editing
okay
sector
so this is for btna which we have given
along with this between there are some
other properties are also available I
can Dot main underscore
container here we would like to provide
position
okay
relative
okay after this position we would like
to also provide the property for navbar
so we are saying never
underscore or let's talk about neighbor
rest of the stats will be offering a
little later with this snap bar we are
providing this width
okay this width will be a hundred
percent
okay this will be a hundred percent and
also we provide height
this height will be 65 pixels
okay provided by position
we are providing absolute
after 30 second display
we are providing Flex
after that we are saying justify content
justify content we are seeing space
around
after that
we are saying align items
this we are giving is Center
okay along with this we are giving this
logo
of type A
so inside this logo we are saying font
family
this phone firmly we are once again
using the same
the one which you have used earlier
you remember Allura and Q result let me
we can use the same whatever we have
used it earlier so same condition you
can use it here so we remember earlier
what we have used in my previous program
okay font family so the same font family
I would like to use it here also
okay so logo a but let me check
somewhere down the line what weight
font family so let me copy this thing
at least here right now okay so we have
a good points family with me which we
have taken it right now to my existing
logo a along with I want to use all
font size
we would like to use 22 pixels
also color
and as usual I would like to you right
okay so that is for logo on which we
have basically applied this a part of
this we would like to also use for never
Webber underscore
item
space use
and here we would like to provide margin
and padding
again 0
followed by line Style
list style sorry
list
style here we are saying none see that
is the benefit of having this Visual
Studio code because sometimes when you
are going wrong it immediately will give
you the idea of like saying like hey
you're going somewhere around that's
what the suggestions were not given to
us so till here we've added furthermore
we'll be adding few more Styles into my
code well never tell you all we have
seen no followed by saying
dot level okay underscore
items followed by valuable which we have
it and along with this we would like to
go ahead with this list items also and
in this list items we need few details
first I'll talk about call Float so
float left for sure then we talk about
color width
width will be 100 pixels
and now we talk about color height
will be 40 pixels
well
float width height we have talked about
now we talk about called background
color
background color we can save Light
Element
s that looks nice
and opacity
opacity we can just give call 0.8
followed by line height
line height I can give call 40 pixels
okay along with this we also want
texture line once again Center
okay this is for these items now under
the same name bar you may have some
other properties also
okay this is for never UL Ali and we can
also have the same property
copy
but along with this Li I can also have
this anchor attack we can select
multiple elements together
so here I would like to offer text
transform
you see this textual form
uppercase followed by color
this color we are saying black
and we're talking about called text
decoration
text decoration we want nothing
along with this I won't display
and as usual it will be a block type
okay that was array and within this
anchor tag I also can have a hover let
me copy the same
and with this anchor I can have the
property name called what
Google
so what property you are expecting for
this
so here in my hover property I can say
background color
and I can use
tomato
okay well after this in the same navbar
items I also want to have after the
anchor tag what should happen so this
conditions I want to utilize because I
want to offer some of the animations
Behavior right over there so what
animations I would like to go ahead that
I need to offer under this navigation
items Li so I just copy this
paste it below but this over which we
are talking about we would like to
change from
to after
okay
after so I'm removing this background
color with this because background color
can be changed to something else so I
can change to White
well let me have few more properties to
be get added first thing we are trying
to say call position
will be absolute
okay we want from left side
left I want to give 50 percent base
after this long bottle
I'm saying 0.
okay now I want to talk about what
transform
we remember to the property available in
CSS and here we are saying
Translate
X and inside this translate X I say
minus 50 percent
okay and here we are saying after that
scale
X
okay and here we're providing what zero
so that's what the condition we want to
provide it for the transform and the
next thing will be transform origin
transform origin if I say 50 percent
and again 50 percent
after this we would like to talk about
width
width will be 100 percent
okay and we also want this height
height will be 2 pixels
okay with hundred percent High 2 pixels
after that we talk about transition
in this transition we can talk about
called transform
okay transform to 50 image
okay so these are so far the details
which are available with us which I
would like to use it in my code
okay that is for after of this anchor
tag so when we talk about hover you
further want to change the behavior over
there so in this case I would like to
use the same
condition I just copy that
and here let me say colon
so you can see
I like
space a colon over colon after
so what conditions you want to use it
here so
transform
okay so here
translate X
okay so here you say minus
50 percent
scalex
1.0
followed by we would like to use again
Dot
number
okay underscore item
okay you will followed by Li followed by
once again UL once again Li and here in
this case we want to offer display none
display
not
Okay so
that's okay and one more conditions I
would like to take it here is
here when I say UL Li colon hover so I
can say Li
colon
over
UL Ali so we will say display
block
that's the condition
okay so so far we have written this much
of CSS we would like to go ahead and try
to implement some of the HTML behavior
and we'll be back to our CSS to make
this possible
okay everyone so we have developed a lot
about CSS it's time for us to move
towards our next
UI that is called the HTML part okay so
here
I've already kept it just for the kind
information I've just downloaded few of
the
images
okay from the internet just to utilize
into my application
I'm going to create
the another
file and give the name called index.html
foreign
let me have this template with me okay
so I have a good template with me now
here uh we want to use some of the
awesome CSS styles for of my usual
development So within my head tag I
would like to use this link
this is for CSS so say link I recorded
style sheet and href equal to now I'm
gonna give the location so this CSS
anyways is there that's called style we
want to say called styles.css and one
more style I would like to use in my
code
but the location will be somewhere else
I am saying
https cdnjs
Dot
cloudflare
dot com slash Ajax slash Libs
slash font
iPhone
awesome okay there is a well-known style
sheet we are giving the version called
5.15.1 slash
see it says slash
all
sorry on Dot Min dot CSS so that is the
location actually
okay now I want to just check whether
this location does exist or not so I'll
just copy this
paste it in my browser to verify
well yes this style does exist so we
would like to go ahead and continue
well I would like to give some title in
case if I want so this is a document I
can just get the name core
website
okay let's keep this W Capital website
development
coming to my body tag here I just want
to give a div
plus equal to
let's give the name called Main
underscore
container okay and also we want to give
ID
equal to
oh that is the dev type for that okay
now along with this I want to give some
other type of Dev tags too where I want
to use it now here within this Dev tag I
want to give another div tag where I
want to provide a nav bar so
equal to never
okay and within the snap bar I want to
use another div tag so it says
plus equal to
logo
okay within this div tag we want to
provide the href
okay a href equal to
here we want to provide this hash
okay
and this will be provided to
home see this is we have got div class
we have called Dev class equal to logo
and under this we are providing this
hashtag and using
simply learned
Solutions
okay that is the first anchor tag the
div tag is getting closed and we would
like to start
another div tag and in this div tag we
would like to say class equal to
in my bar underscore
items
okay within this div type we would like
to use this you will and within this URL
I would like to use this Ally okay and
in this Ally uh we would like to bring
some
ahref equal to hash
that is the link which I need to provide
okay so in this anchor tag we want to
provide a location called home here this
is the first list item which is there
like this I can provide some other list
items too like I didn't talk about call
about using hash
about and here we say
about here so this anchor tag is getting
close
okay and here before I close this list
item here we would like to take another
UL tag
okay in this you will tag we would like
to paste this list item again and here
with this hash we can just give the name
call
something whichever you want to give it
again
it
would like and
empty
so after that UL is also getting closed
Li is also getting closed here
okay after this we can provide few more
Ally tags here
okay so href equal to here we would like
to provide a real URL remove the hashtag
and say
https
slash
corporate python
training okay and here you'll be giving
the option called services
This falls into the category of what
services like this we would like to
provide one more anchor tag for contact
us
let's see
contact
one more for our team
okay and here we say
power t
okay let me go back to my index.html
file and check the status
well it looks pretty nice now here we
have got simply learn solution with us
and right inside you can see now here in
about you see how the things are working
for me this links are coming up
automatically it came because here if
you remember in my code
when I was saying this about
okay this was a part of our current code
and due to that it is now making it
possible for us and that is possible
because here in y style.css
if you remember we were using this a
kind of
never UL Li
okay so the more I try to hover
okay so this was giving me the complete
details and due to that I was in
position to get all the details so it
looks pretty nice
okay so going forward what I would like
to do is within my program as I could
see in my index.html file we have
provided this tag so UL is getting close
this div is getting close this tip is
also getting closed okay
now here we would like to start another
table
we say Dev class equal to Banner image
final underscore
English
okay now within this tip I would like to
use one more div tag with intensitive we
say
class equal to
Banner underscore
content
okay Banner underscore contract now
within this div class we would like to
use this H1
here we can say
welcome to
welcome to Simply learn okay after this
Break Tag as you know that is a for
break and now
this is fan tag we can say
words
okay
number one boot camp
okay here the instrument type is getting
closed after that the paragraph tag
within this paragraph We Can Say
get certified
get
ahead
this value
after this the dev type is getting
closed the second tip deck is also
getting close let me check
okay so that we need to organize it
uh in a better way so but initially we
have a god welcome to safety learn words
number one boot camp thumb
how my look and feel is really gonna
help because this Banner part I want to
organize it because I do not have a CSS
for this
clear so certainly I need a CSS to
organize this particular Banner
getting it because when you talk about
code Banner content so I need to tell
where it needs to go because I also
would have some banned image also too so
I'll go back to my CSS now and in my
style CSS here let me say Banner content
Banner underscore
content
and here we can save
text align
enter and say color
you can see
white smoke
okay and also within this Banner content
foreign
tag
within this H1 tag you have to just set
text transform
uppercase
and line height
line height 38 pixels
okay and
margin bottom
this margin bottom we want to use 15
pixels
okay
so that's when we have it let me close
this
sorry
and here we want to use the remove
property called Banner content
with H1 and the spine tag so that I can
change the color so here
Banner content
H1 we also want to use
pattern tag within this I want to say
color and you can just say
tomato and let's check does it affect my
application yes exactly it does affect
now you can see it is somewhere coming
down the line like this
okay so I can further change it
to my application
like if I talk about about it and all so
this I can change it for sure because if
I have some images also those images I
also want to change
towards my application but it is just a
simple part
we are talking about call Banner code
and we have also have to take some
images too for this ballet image
so let's go back and talk about our
index.html file and see what some of the
banners I want to utilize it here
okay now when we talk about get ahead I
certainly need some of the banner image
too but Banner image is not available so
let me go back and try to use some
Banner image whichever we have to Define
under my CSS okay so here in my style
CSS let me go here and say dot
Banner underscore
image
in this Banner image we have to say
background URL
background colon for you to say URL and
in this URL we have to use this image
called images
slash P4
dot JPC
that will be my image and also we would
like to use one very common option that
is called No repeat so that it should
not repeat it and I want to fix it to
the top
and in a center
okay now let's check
perfect it is coming up but it is not
looking as good as it looks like it so
we want to use few more important things
think this background size
background size
cover and also want to use width
width I want to use hundred percent
and height
we want to use it because 600 percent
okay display
we want to use it Flex
and justify content
we want to use it called Center
and align items
Center let's check this out
okay now you can see it looks pretty
better compared to the previous version
whatever we have written it
but this image needs to be look even
more better
okay and the content needs to be more
awesome but anyways that is the first
thing which we have written after that
we have to write an About Us and other
areas but that is initially which I
would like to make it even more better
and more look
okay
okay so we have seen the value still
call option called get certified get
ahead the div tag is getting closed and
I want to use another
div and inside this div we want to say
class equal to about
okay and
I'll equal to about
okay
and within this div tag I want to use
this H1 tag with the search one tag I
say
class equal to
title
okay here I want to say
about us
ual time is closed after that I want to
Define this paragraph and want to give
some details about a simple learner okay
like
and talk about simply learn
words number one
training okay we can just uh
provide you know some details training
providers
that's it so we can write it that much
about in paragraph tag and we can use
this div again
within this tip we say to
plus equal to
bdn and say
a
href equal to
and in this exercise we would like to
see it
colon
simply learn
dot com okay slash
resources and here we can just give the
option name call
none
more
to this anchor tag the div tag is
getting close later on
okay but now just like until we have
provided here we can also offer the
details with regards to your services so
I can just copy this thing
and provide about the services so you
can say
Services ID equal to
services and you can provide anything
whichever you would like to provide
title is the same about us we can say
our services
so we can give any details if you want
okay paragraph
now here after this paragraph using div
class equal to
div
underscore services
and we may not have any hrf right over
here so we're removing this hrf tag
okay div class equal to diff or signals
d i
interrupt inter Services here you want
to use another div tag and in this Dev
tag we want to say
class equal to
enter underscore
underscore
[Music]
item we have to basically provide and
within this I have to use this option
called IMG SRC equal to now you have to
provide a location so I'm saying
under this images folder we have a call
services
one
dot jpg alt equal to in case of the
service is not available you can just
say
service underscore image
okay within this once this is close you
would like to use a S3 tag now
and in this H3 tag I just say
plus equal to
sub underscore
title and here we get the title name
called
web development let me go back and check
yeah so I can see this option called
about assist coming up learn more if I
talk about learn more you see I'm taking
you to the website of this simply
learned resources which are available to
us so this link is working perfectly
fine
and uh I can see here called our
services
it is a thing well going back so we have
a call
this our services
so alt equal to
Services underscore image SD class equal
to subtitle web development and uh
that's it
so the div tag is getting closed here
and I may choose to talk to words Dev
service item so let me have
another div tag here and in this div tag
we saved
class equal to
div underscore
Services underscore item
if underscore Services underscore item
okay now within this Dev tag
okay so what you want to offer now I
want to offer some again certain images
so what those images will be let me try
to copy this
and the S3 Tag 2 let me copy this again
so this one I'm giving call service to
service underscore images server
underscore title rather than using web
development we can say app development
okay
so this div tag I will copy it again
which is getting closed and try to use
one more
So Divine dispose service underscore
item again images I'll say
service 3 instead service image and here
I can say online certification
online certification
okay
so like this
all the 3D tags are getting close now
and after that we will start meanwhile
let me check
so these image sizes are pretty big so I
just want to make them small but
initially they are okay
okay you can see we have called our
services
Okay so
you can see like web development
so image sizes are pretty big which we
can make them small to cover up the way
they are supposed to but this way we'll
be doing it little later on let's go
ahead and talk about the complete HTML
portion which we want to complete it now
okay so till online certification we
have taken so also the three div tags
are getting closed now here onwards we
want to start the another tip
of it with this tip we want to say class
equal to
equal to we want to use contactless
we want to say contact us and here
ID equal to
contact us
let me try to wrap it with this single
quotes
and here we will use this H1 tag within
this H1 tag we say
class equal to
title here and here I say contact us
contact us okay that is for the Post H1
tag we are using it now after that let's
start with another Dev tag with this div
we want to use class
equal to
form
underscore
wrapper
okay div class equal to what form
underscore what wrapper
div again
okay
class equal to
form underscore what input and here we
say
the input tag
so it is the input tab equal to what a
checkbox for me so I would like to say
text instead input type equal to what
text and just say remove the name and ID
and say
placeholder equal to
email okay so this div tag is getting
closed after that I can also use
foreign
so for
I would say subject as well as for
message I copy this
form input so once again placeholder
subject
and once again placeholder equal to what
[Music]
three options we are using it right now
okay there
after this once it is over we would like
to use another div tag
and do
class equal to
BTN
and within this I want to use some
anchor diagram
a href equal to hash
of equal to one hash
and want to use submit
okay and that's it
now
now you can see we have got these three
properties are coming up at the end
but certainly we can go back and try to
fix those images which are there behind
the scene
okay using what the style
so first important thing is we have got
this images with us
what those images are if we just check
here you have a call diff service item
okay we have a call what Dev service
item so that we want to change it but
before that I will go back to my style
and after this H1 span we want to use
for thought
about
okay dot
service represented
service
or I can say services
here we talk about Dot
contact us
we also talk about dot dot
our team
okay
so these four properties we are going to
use it by saying
texture line
Center and
padding five percent
10 percent
okay now we talk about services so we're
saying Dot
services with the services we can say
background
White
smoke
now we would like to provide the div
Services where we have this options with
us we say dot div underscore
services
here
margin top
25 pixels
from margin top ESC after that display
your selecting is called type splx also
justify contents
of types based between
for Dev Services now in this div
Services we may get many different type
of options
okay this is the first step service now
in the same option Dot
Dev services
or space
we talk about div Services underscore
item
okay and here we want to save it
30 percent
okay now I copy the screen
in this div Services item
so we want to use
image font that is the most important
area here we say width
100 percent
okay and margin button
okay margin bottom 25 pixels
okay
okay now you can see this images looks
pretty nice
yeah looks better so that's how you see
your websites are really creating some
difference compared to the previous one
now they are aligned properly and you
can see here these images are really
nice
okay that's the benefit so we have this
let me call requests
yeah and once this image part is closed
we would like to talk about H3 part
let me copy this
item
and with this item we say
and this S3 we say color
tomato and margin bottom
we say 15 pixels
okay for this S3 and when it comes to
this text boxes
certainly you can change the look and
feel how you really want it so for this
you can say dot
form underscore Ripple
of underscore
input
okay form wrapper form input
we say margin hyphen bottom
15 pixels
okay perform input
now in a similar line uh form input we
may have about text area
input
text is here and in this text area we
I want to offer some of the details like
I'm talking about like in width we talk
about padding let's talk about like a
width I'm saying 250 pixels
okay we start adding
Research Road pixels
and
20 pixels we talk about
height
80 pixels we talk about resize
we talk about none
with a border
this bottle is a 1 pixels
call it
and
White
this is for this and in a similar one I
can use it for the text box so form
colon input
whatever we have used it form wrapper
form input so let me copy this
okay form input and here we say input
equal to
type of text
so what
combination you'll be using so I'll be
using width padding and border
copy
or you need which party and Border
height and freak size we're removing it
and
awesome so they look pretty nice okay so
we have this three text boxes with us
and all are looking nice the way we are
expecting from our application okay so
that's the one which my application is
offering about this text area and all so
that looks really nice the way we are
expecting right now
Okay so
what are the areas we have seen Tiff
Services item
and everything whichever you are saying
like this
so let's go back and check to my
index.html file
so we have a call
form wrapper which is the outermost
okay
you see now here it contains lot many
things
so here in my
program when I see like form wrapper
okay form underscore wrapper dot form
input and uh
talk about like the other details
talk about input type equal to text
you see like the border is like that
so if you want to have this border some
different color
can certainly use black
and now you can see it looks pretty nice
because earlier it was looking like
pretty much different now at least I can
see here the location has been given
okay uh so going back towards the
previous
HTML page so we had a call a submit
button with us okay after this
all three div tags are getting closed
and now onwards we would like to start
working with field details
obvious thing do
so do
plus equal to
our team and
ID equal to
name again
okay and now we want to use this H1 tag
here this H1 tag we say
class
equal to title and here I say
our team in a H1 tag now once it is over
we will use again another div tag which
having
class equal to our team wrapper
our
team
contact core
rubber
now within the step tag
we want to use one more div tag here in
this class equal to
team underscore or team iPhone one
phase 3.
now here we will be using a lot of other
Dev tags inside this like
I say div
class equal to team members
team members
okay and uh data hyphen name equal to we
can give any name right let's give the
name call
it's like space key okay and within this
I want to use one image tag
IMG space SRC equal to
Images slash team one
dot jpeg
okay so that's the first thing
we have it so this div tag is closed now
uh I copy the same
but total I want to use this three one
two
three
and here team members I would like to
change the name here rather than it
actually let me get the name called
technology and
one more
that is called
okay and change the name to two
4.5 free
okay so this is the first div we have
used it so this div tag is getting
closed right over here along with this
this is the second depth attack is
getting closed so after having this
two div tags closed we want to use
another one so for team 2.
okay so I just copy the scene
okay uh
I would like to go ahead with
team toting so team members
and here I would like to say four five
or
five
six and change the name like
you can keep anything I just give it a
name called suppose
Aryan
foreign
so these names we are using it now let's
go back and see how it really looks
so these images are coming like that
okay so we want to use those images in
somewhere not like this or horizontal
vertical so this spot fix that issue I
have to once again look back to where to
my styles
okay where this option can be used in
better way I like to go back to my
style.css and want to use the first
option called dot over 3.
background
sorry
background now here we say
white smoke
now
again
our team
wrapper
so in this I would like to say display
Flex
and flex Direction
face between
oh sorry column
let's check how it really looks like it
this is a normal change
but
certainly few more classes can really
make a difference so our team
okay underscore Rebel let's check this
is the same name we have used it
is everything
now in the same way we want to use this
team
so again our team wrapper
okay
Dot
team
display
and justify contents
space between
okay
now here when we talk about t we also
want to say
our team underscore rapper Dot
team underscore
members
here we would like to give bit
how much 30 percent
and height
this will be Auto
and here we'll be having cursor
pointer for sure and overflow
hidden
and position
relative
this is what team members
now you can see it looks better now now
we have to basically divide those
because we have got separate team
members are available so we have to also
divide them two so here after that we
want to say
Dot
our team wrapper and again Dot
team members
a space IMG
these images we say on display
block
width
100 percent
okay
height
Auto
okay
transition
transition or transition I can say or
type all
like this
okay and in a similar way
copy this team
and we'll say members
over image
and we can say
transform
a scale
1.1
that's it
okay so we have this
look and feel appeared okay with
transition image over so they're all
ready with us
okay everybody so after writing all
those the only difference I made it like
I had used hyphen but I'm using
underscore here finally when I see my
look and feel
of this I can see now it is moving you
can see now it is all moving okay so
that gives me the confidence of like yes
exactly the code is working the way it
was expected earlier in my index.html
file
okay so once this portion is over okay
we want to go ahead so three tip tags
are getting close one two and three and
here
we would like to start working with the
footer so here we start
footer
so operating this water I say class
equal to
okay now after this I use container
there
div class equal to what container and
again div
equal to
true
okay now div class equal to row again
another div
equal to
footer hyphen colon
converter iPhone column now let me use
H4 within the search for I say company
okay after this we want to use this UL
within this URL once again I want to use
some link items
list items within this list item
a
equal to
this hrf tag we want to save
HTTP okay we have already used the
simply learn.com URL
yeah
let me copy this
come down
https simplylean.com rather than
resources I can say about it
about iPhone us
and here we say about this
so it is getting closed
so I copy this line again
okay so one more thing I want to use it
think HR is equal to
hash and here you will say
our team
okay after that
we want to offer the careers to be safe
and we want to use
careers
here
reviews
concept
aluminum speak
so this is the detail of this so the UL
tag is getting close
and after this you will attack is
getting closed uh
we want to use one more Dev class equal
to footer hyphen column
okay I copy this
it is getting closed here
okay so do class equal to photo hyphen
column so rather than using company we
want to use this cover
discover and here in this discover we
say simplyline.com and here we have this
option calls kill up
hyphen
free iPhone
online hyphen
order
okay so here we will give the name call
skill up
okay after this
we have this called careers we say
resources
[Music]
here we can give the name called
resources again
resources we have called tutorials
tutorials
research
tutorials here
so like this we can create as my number
of URLs as I want
okay
so once it is over
let me copy this again
and here photo column we say followers
column
as
or else we can say this option name
called work with us
in this world because we can have
some options with us in UL
remove those two
in this we would like to say guest
blogging
we say
guest blogging
yes blogging we can say blog is kissed
blog I'll meet
guest another link which I have it here
that is called become our trainer
here we say
become
hyphen our iPhone
trainer and reset
become an instructor
okay so like that you're offering it and
once it is done I can copy it once again
this div
and provide few more photo hyphen column
followers
okay and
[Music]
follow us we would like to use another
tip
foreign
hyphen
length and this divide will be closed
later
okay
the class equal to Social Links in this
I can have some facebook.com and you
know twitter.com and many more names I
can take it so here in our Dev class
equal to social link here I will not be
using any URL here I will not be using
any Ally here
okay so I'm closing this you're gonna
like
closing this URL and I like to
well simplylamp.com or else we can just
give the name called twitter.com
okay
twitter.com slash
simply learn
Okay so
we can offer the user
to follow solar
Instagram also or to the Twitter also so
here we say
a hdf but what we need to give it so we
can see twitter.com
simply learn
we remove this values whichever we have
it
so instead we use this I
okay and in this I I say
equal to
have your iPhone Twitter
okay anchor tag is closed so in case if
you want to talk about like an
typical
[Music]
you know Instagram that Instagram also
you can use it now so here
we say http www
dot install
we say instagram.com okay slash
simply learn underscore
underscore e-learning
okay and I want to use the same option
there also I
enter with this
remove this
okay so here just give the name for
every hyphen
Instagram
now let's go back and check
okay so you can see now we have got this
links coming up for Facebook as well as
what of this Instagram so that looks
really nice that gives us a feeling of
yes exactly the code the way we are
looking forward for it is working the
way it was expected
okay and if we want to offer any other
type of details that also you can offer
but this is the first thing which we
have taken so this is the navigation
links are available these navigation
links
you could also change the way they
always look forward for so I'll be
providing some links which we can later
on use it
okay everyone so finally we are all
ready so I have basically added some of
the additional styles to my code you can
see here from this point onwards we've
added this image URL
this is for body this is for Star
container row UL this is for footer this
is for footer column so because we are
also using some photo portions into my
code as you can see we have a call photo
column and photo class equal to what
footer so implemented this photo
background color equal to Black we have
used it padding 70 pixels photo column
footer column because we are using this
H4 tag also if you remember like we're
using this H4 tag also so for all H4
tags this would be the basic setting
for footer column H4 before we would
like to give the contents like this by
giving this background color height box
sizing width and the null
photo column you will and I not last set
we're gonna give this margin bottom and
this is the style for photo column URL
Li and list items
okay and here you can see this font size
we're giving it this is for Google this
is for photo column where we have of our
Social Links whichever we have created
so it is showing me that display inline
block margin border radius and this is
for Social Links when I try to click on
or over it so the color will change to
this white color and the media this is
for responsiveness to make sure like in
case if I reduce the size of my browser
they look better the way it is expected
so when the line size will change to 720
pixels so this color will be change and
this is the styles for Arrow photo one
this is all we have implemented and
finally my application when I refresh it
actually looks like that see that this
is the photo area of my application
so I'm sure that this looks even more
better and convenient because when I try
to reduce the size you see now it's
still gonna give you the responsiveness
can you see this now this is going to
give you the responsiveness reason
because here we are using this Logic for
media when the change of width will to
720 pixels if it is going to 767 pixels
so like that you implement that so guys
our project is now ready I'm sure that
you enjoyed thank you very much for
enjoying this project so finally our
application is set and our application
is working the way it is supposed to
work for us question stands for
hypertext markup language it is the most
widely used language for developing web
applications it was created by bonusly
in the year 1991 but it was published in
the year 1995. html4 was a popular
breakthrough version and got published
in the year 1991. this version gained a
lot of popularity and was adopted all
over the glow for developing web
applications so without further Ado
let's get started with the interview
questions based on HTML
the first question
what is HTML HTML stands for hypertext
markup language and it is the language
of the internet it is a standard text
formatting language used for creating
and displaying pages on internet HTML
documents are made up of the elements
and tags that formatted properly and
display it on pages
so we have our next question now what
are HTML tags so the answer for this
question is HTML tasks are used for
placing the elements in a proper and
appropriate format tags use the symbols
greater than and less than to set them
apart from the HTML content the HTML
tags need not to be closed always for
example in case of images the closing
tags are not required for an image tag
now followed by the second question we
have our third question what are HTML
attributes the attributes are the
properties that can be added to an HTML
tag that changed the way the tag behaves
or displayed for example an image tag an
image stack has SRC attribute with which
you can use the source from which you
have to display the image from
now the attributes are added right after
the name of the HTML tag inside the
brackets the attributes can only be
added to opening or self-closing tags
but never in closing tax
now followed by third question we have
our next question what has Mark you in
HTML Mark U is used for scrolling text
on a web page it Scrolls the image or
text up down left or right automatically
to apply for a mark you you have to use
Smart View tags now we have our first
question how do you separate a section
of text in HTML we separate a section of
text in HTML using the below tags which
are the Break Tag paragraph tag and
block code The Break Tag is used to
separate a line of text it breaks the
current line and shifts the flow of the
text line to a new line followed by that
we have the paragraph line the paragraph
line is used to write a paragraph of
text and third one the block code the
block code tag is used to define large
quoted sections now we have our sixth
question Define the types of lists in
HTML so we have the three types of list
in HTML which are the ordered list
unordered list and definition list so
first we'll discuss the audit list the
ordered list uses ol tag and displays
elements in a numbered format next we
have the unordered list the unordered
list uses UL tag and displays elements
in a bulleted format thirdly we have the
definition list the definition list uses
DL DT and DD tags and displace elements
in the form of definition like a
dictionary
next we have our seventh question how do
you align list of elements in an HTML
file we can align the list elements in
an HTML file by using indents if you
indent each nested list and further than
the parent list then you can easily
align and determine the various lists
and the elements that it contains now we
have our eighth question differentiate
between ordered list and unordered list
so the answer for this question is an
unordered list uses UL tags and each
element of the list as written between
Li tags the items are displayed as
bullets rather than numbers now coming
into ordered list so for creating an
ordered list you'll be using ol tax and
each element inside the list as written
using Li tags the list items are
displayed using numbers rather than
bullet points now we have a sample on
the screen right now so the first three
elements are a set of unordered lists
which are represented using bullet tax
and the second set which is the coffee
tea and milk is an ordered list which is
represented using numbers
now moving ahead we have the ninth
question how do you display a table in
HTML web page so the table in HTML can
be created or displayed using the table
tag
so it also uses to manage the layout of
the page for example header section
navigation bar body content photo
section etc etc so given below our list
of HTML tags used for displaying table
in an HTML web page so we have table TR
th etc etc table is used to define a
table TR is used to define a row in a
table t h for header TD for a cell
caption is used to define a caption and
we have the call group which is used to
specify a group of one or more columns
in a table for formatting next we have
call which is used with call group
element to specify column properties for
each column next we have t body which is
used to group The Body content in a
table next we have t head T footer which
are used for header content and footer
content respectively moving forward we
have our 10th question how do you
display the given table in an HTML web
page so the answer for this question is
written on the right side part of my
screen this is the sample code which you
can use to represent or display a table
which is given in this particular format
over here now followed by this we have
our 11th question how do we insert a
comment in HTML so the answer for this
question is we can insert a comment in
HTML by beginning with lesser than sign
and ending with a greater than sign for
example as shown in the right side part
of my screen which is hello world now
moving ahead we have our 12th question
how do you insert a copyright symbol in
HTML so you can insert a copyright
symbol by using Ampersand copy semicolon
or Ampersand hashtag 169 semicolon in an
HTML file now moving ahead we have our
13th question so what is a white space
in HTML so the answer for this question
is an empty sequence of space characters
is called as white space in HTML this
white space is considered as a single
space character in HTML white space
helps the browser to merge multiple
spaces into one single space and so
taking care of indentation becomes
easier
white space helps in better organizing
the content and tax making them readable
and easy to understand with this let's
move into the 14th question
how do you create links in different
sections within the same HTML web page
so the answer is Anchor text we can use
anchor tag along with referencing
through the use of hashtag symbol to
create several links to different
sections within the same web page moving
ahead we have the 15th question how do
you create a hyperlink in HTML so the
answer is we can use anchor tag again
here the same thing we can use anchor
tag to create a hyperlink within the
HTML that links to another web page the
hyperlink can be added to images too now
moving ahead into our 16th question
Define an image map so the answer for
this question is an image map in HTML
helps in linking with the different
kinds of web pages using this single
image it can be used for defining spaces
in the images that are made part of the
image mapping process
moving ahead we have our 17th question
why do we use stylesheet in HTML a style
sheet helps in creating a well-defined
template for HTML web page that is both
consistent as well as portable a single
style sheet template can be linked to
various web pages which makes it easier
to maintain and change the look of the
website now the 18th question what is
semantic in HTML
so the answer for this question is
semantic HTML is a coding style it is
the use of HTML markup to reinforce the
semantics or the meaning of the content
for example the semantic HTML B tag is
not used for both statement as well as
itac which is not used for italic
instead we use strong and EM text now
followed by the 18th question we have
our 19th question what is SVG in HTML so
the HTML SVG is used to describe the
vector or raster Graphics SVG images and
their behaviors are defined in XML text
sheets it is mostly used for Vector type
diagrams like pie charts two dimensional
graphs in an x y coordinate system now
moving ahead we have our 20th question
what would happen if there is no text
between the HTML tags so the answer for
this question is really simple there
would be nothing to format if there is
no text present in between the tags
therefore nothing will appear on the
screen some tags such as the tax without
closing tag like image tag do not
require any text between them now
followed by the 28th question we have
our next question how do you create
nested web pages in an HTML so nested
web pages basically mean a web page
within a web page we can create nested
web pages and HTML using the built-in
iframe tag the HTML live frame tag
defines an inline frame for example
which is displayed on the right side
part of my screen you can see the iframe
source which redirects the user to
Simply learns official webpage
now followed by that we have our 20
second question how do you add buttons
in HTML so we can use the built-in
button tag in HTML to add buttons to the
HTML web page so on the right hand part
of my screen you can see the
implementation of button to an HTML web
page now followed by 20 second question
we have our 23rd question what are the
different types of headings in HTML so
the answer for this question is there
are basically six types of heading tags
in HTML which are defined with H1 to H6
tags
each type of the heading tag displays
different text size from another where
H1 is being the largest and H6 is being
the smallest so on the right hand part
of my screen you can see the
implementation of heading tags from H1
to H6 now the
output for this particular code segment
is the H1 H2 s3h4 H5 H6 so you can see
that H1 is being the biggest one and H6
is being the smallest one now moving
ahead into our 24th question how do you
insert an image in the HTML web page so
the answer for this question is you can
insert an image in the HTML web page by
using the following code which is
displayed on the right side part of my
screen you can see we have a image
source is equals to tulip.jpeg which is
used for inserting an image into your
HTML web page
now our 25th question what is the alt
attribute in HTML now the answer for
this question is the alt attribute is
used for displaying the text and place
of an image whenever the image cannot be
loaded you to any technical issue so
basically when you have four internet
connection and you are trying to load an
image you can see some sort of text in
place of an image so that particular
text is nothing but the alt attribute
now moving ahead we have our 26th
question how are hyperlinks inserted in
the HTML web page you can insert a
hyperlink in the HTML web page by using
the following code which is present on
the right side part of my screen you can
use the ank attack along with h
reference and inside that particular tag
you can use the URL to which you want
your users to redirect to now followed
by this we have our 27th question how do
you add color to the text in HTML so the
answer for this question is you can add
color to the text by using the following
code which is present on the right side
part of my screen where you can add a
red color and blue color green color to
this particular paragraph and headings
now followed by 27th question we have
our 28th question how do you add CSS
styling in HTML so there are three
particular ways to add CSS to your HTML
there are inline CSS external style
sheet and internal style sheet we'll
discuss each of these methods in a bit
more detail first we have the inline CSS
so it is used when less amount of
styling is needed or in cases where only
a single element has to be styled to use
inline Styles add the style attribute in
the relevant tag now moving ahead we
have the external style sheet this is
used when the style is applied to many
elements or HTML pages each page must
link to the style sheet using the link
tag
now we have the last one which is the
internal style sheet it is used when a
single HTML document has a unique style
and several elements need to be styled
to follow the format internal stylesheet
is added in the head section of the HTML
Page by style tag now followed by this
we have our 29th question what hierarchy
do the style sheets follow
the answer for this question is if a
single selector includes three different
style definitions the definition that is
closest to the actual tag takes
precedence inline style takes priority
over embedded style sheets which takes
priority over external style sheets now
our last question for the session today
how do you add JavaScript to an HTML web
page so the answer for this question is
we basically have three methods to add a
JavaScript to our HTML webpage they are
inline script block and external
Javascript file first we'll discuss the
inline you can add JavaScript to your
HTML elements directly whenever a
certain event occurs JavaScript code can
be added using attributes of the HTML
tags that supported now the next one
that is the script log you can define a
script block anywhere inside the HTML
code which will get executed as soon as
the browser reaches to that part of the
document this is why script locks are
usually added at the end part of the
HTML documents now the last one that is
the external Javascript file you can
also add or import the JavaScript code
from a separate file and keep your HTML
code clutter free this is especially
useful if there is a large amount of
scripting added to the HTML web page so
this session will be about become a
front-end developer so let us begin
we are going to discuss the things you
need to know to become a web developer
first we will start with basic skills
which every web developer must know
before moving into more advanced web
Frameworks then we will understand what
react is and why it is so popular after
that we will go through another web
framework called angular
then we will also get to know about a
comparatively new front-end framework
called view in the end we will go
through the front-end developer salary
Trends which will give you an Insight of
the job market
so without further Ado let's get started
first the basic skills let us understand
what basic skills are required to become
a web developer there are a few
recommendations in that you must learn
for either path these are the common
things every programmer should know
the first one is the GitHub
so git is a free open source version
control system that enables
collaborations in a particular project
it is designed to handle both small and
large scale projects git is a tool used
to save code and create different
versions to better manage the feature
updates in the product or an application
so followed by the GitHub the next
important thing we have is today
structures and algorithms a data
structure is the location used to store
and organize data an algorithm is a
collection of steps to solve a
particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
allow us to write efficient and fast
computer programs
so followed by data structures and
algorithms we have the text editor get
familiar with the text editor of your
choice
Visual Studio code is the top choice for
most of the web developers and my
personal choice too because of the large
support of languages and of course the
speed
the text editor is where you write all
your code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
the command line is an important tool to
get familiar with it is how you run your
code after writing it on a text editor
the better you are on the command line
the more efficient you will be asked to
developer
so followed by the command line we have
the HTTP and https the HTTP protocol is
the backbone of the internet
it handles requests and responses from a
web application it is mandatory for a
web developer to have good knowledge of
both HTTP and https in order to build
fast and responsive web applications
now that we know what basic skills are
required to become a front-end developer
let's discuss about the most popular
front-end library that has to react
now what exactly react is
so react as a front-end JavaScript
library used for building beautiful user
interface components
it is an open source meaning it can be
used in your commercial projects without
any restrictions
it is also component based and these
components can be used again and again
promoting code reusability
it is an MVC or model view controller
architecture react is the V responsible
for how the application looks and feels
for the end user now why should you
learn react react has always been in
high performance as it uses virtual Dom
rather in real Dom so basically Dom
stands for document object model and is
used by every internet browser for
rendering a web page or an application
react can also be easily integrated with
other JavaScript Frameworks like node.js
resulting in the development of a
completely new web application including
front-end and the backend
it is comparatively easy to maintain
large scale applications written in
react because it highly promotes code
reusability and code readability
so followed by react the next important
thing we have is the angular
we have an idea of what react is but it
is not the only framework used for
building user interfaces so now let us
know about angular
so now what exactly angular is
angular unlike react is a fully fledged
framework for web application
development which usually does not
require additional libraries for
implementing additional functionalities
like routing
it is also open source and backed by
Google and as regularly updated
resulting in constantly improved
performance and addition of new features
in terms of performance it respect to be
much slower than react but with the
recent versions performance seems to be
on par with react
now why should you learn angular angular
is one of the most stable Frameworks out
there it is also the most complete
meaning you don't have the need to
integrate with other Frameworks since
it's pretty much includes everything for
the web development of a complete web
application
angular backed by Google is safe choice
for using in long-term project since it
is not going anywhere anytime soon
angular is obviously used by Google for
its web applications and also used by
other large-scale companies creating a
lot of job opportunities now followed by
angular the next one we have is the view
now that we know quite a bit about the
two popular front-end Frameworks namely
reactant angular let's now go ahead into
view and learn a bit more about view.js
Library
now what exactly is View
viewers are lightweight and open source
Progressive JavaScript framework used
for developing interactive web user
interfaces
integrated with other libraries to
develop a complete web application
like react vue.js is mainly focused on
The View part of the web application and
hence it's bit faster when compared to
angular which has a complete web
application solution
view.js is commonly referred to as View
and pronounced as vue.js or view is
rightly so
now why should you learn View
any beginner web developer can easily
understand View and start building their
own web user interfaces
like react view also uses virtual Dom
result again better performance and it
also uses the component-based code
design promoting code reusability and
code readability
vue.js has become popular in recent
times and many companies are starting to
use it owing to its lightweight
performance and easy integration with
other web libraries and Frameworks
now with this let's move into the next
section where we will discuss about the
front-end developer salary trends now
that we know what skills we need to
become a front-end developer let's now
have a look into the cell regions of a
front-end developer
front-end developers are always in high
demand since new web applications are
launched and managed continuously
there are generally offered General
salaries across the globe
the salaries also depend on the factors
like Frameworks skills and the work
experience the average salary of a
front-end developer in India is 5 lakh
6000 rupees per annum the average salary
of a front-end developer in United
States is 76
929 US dollars per annum this session
will be about web development roadmap in
2021 so let us begin
assuming that you know what web
development is the roadmap is divided
into three sections the first section is
all about the common skills which every
web developer should know while the
second and third are about front and and
the back end development the main areas
of web development
so you can either learn front-end or
backend or both depending upon your
choice so if you want to become a full
stack web developer then you have to
learn both front end and the back end
there is no escaping there in the end we
will also go through the salaries of web
developer so without further Ado let's
get started
the first one that is the common skills
let us understand the basic skills that
you require to become a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path these are
the common things every programmer
should know
the first one is gith is a free and open
source version control system that
enables collaboration in a particular
project it is designed to handle both
small and large scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the future updates in a product
or application
the next one is the data structures and
algorithms a data structure is a
location used to store and organize data
an algorithm is a collection of steps to
solve a particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
will allow us to write efficient and
fast computer programs
followed by data structures we have the
text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice next Visual Studio is a Top
Choice of the most web developers and my
personal choice too because it has a
large support of languages and of course
this speed
next text editor is where you write all
your code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
a command line is an important tool that
you need to get familiar with it is how
you run your code after writing your
code on the text editor
the better you are on the command line
the most efficient you will be as a
developer so followed by command line
interface you have the HTTP or https the
HTTP protocol is a backbone of the
internet it handles the requests and
responses of a web application
it is mandatory for a web developer to
have good knowledge of both HTTP and
https in order to build a fast and
responsive web application
so followed by Common skills we have the
front-end developer
front-end development is all about
developing the user interface and its
interaction with the client end let's go
ahead and look into this field of web
development there are a few things that
you must know for becoming a front-end
developer let's discuss these things
so the first one is the web development
Basics it is necessary to know the
basics of web before moving on to
programming languages next you should
know stuff like a web applications
protocols like HTTP and web development
in general so followed by web
development Basics we have the HTML and
CSS HTML and CSS are the backbones of
any website HTML provides the structure
while CSS provides the style to make
them visually appealing
mastering these two technologies is a
must to become a front-end developer
browser in the end renders HTML and CSS
on the web page regardless of the
technology used to develop that page
followed by sdml and CSS we have the
JavaScript JavaScript is an extremely
important technology that every web
developer should learn most of the
popular web Frameworks like react.js and
node.js are built upon the JavaScript
JavaScript makes the web application
select by adding interactivity and
dynamic updating of web applications
followed by JavaScript we have the
typescript
typescript can be considered as an
extension of JavaScript angular uses
typescript as a space language it adds
type safety to JavaScript to catch
errors in the development phase it also
helps in developing object oriented code
for JavaScript so followed by typescript
we have the angular
angular is a web framework used to
create a single phase applications
it is packed by Google therefore
learning angular is a good choice for a
modern web developer
so followed by angular we have react.js
react is a popular library for
developing fast and responsive web
applications
it is backed by Facebook and quite
popular because of its Simplicity and
performance
it allows you to create a reusable
components that can be used to create
modern web applications
so followed by react.js we have view JS
view is like other front-end Frameworks
that is used for building user
interfaces
it is comparatively easier to integrate
view with other libraries or existing
projects
it is a newer framework but it has
really picked up speed last year and
been adopted more
now followed by the front-end developer
we have the backend Developers
so back-end development is more about
carrying how application works and
ensure that it keeps running smoothly
let's go ahead and know more about this
field of web development there are a few
things that you must learn from becoming
a back-end developer let us discuss
those things
so the first one is the node.js node.js
is a JavaScript runtime built on
Chrome's V8 JavaScript engine it allows
you to develop a complete web
application using JavaScript
it is best suited to be used for web
applications in conjunction with
JavaScript Frameworks like react.js
so followed by node.js we have python
python is a popular language used in
various fields of tech applications
Django is a back-end framework based on
python used for server-side scripting it
is also known for its speed and
efficiency python is also a easy to get
started with programming language if
this is your first time coding followed
by python we have Java
Java has been the most used language for
a long time it is primarily used for
backend development you can either use
core Java or Java with springboard for
high performance backend next we have
next we have Ruby Ruby is a dynamic
programming language that focuses mainly
on Simplicity it has a syntax that is
very easy to read and close to English
language phrases
the web framework Ruby on Rails is
popularly used for developing back-end
systems so followed by Ruby we have PHP
and MySQL PHP although tweeted as a hard
to learn language is still the easiest
way to write a server-side code at least
50 percent of the internet runs on PHP
and MySQL
MySQL is the most popular database for
storing data of a web application now
followed by the backend developer we
will enter the next important stage of
web development roadmap in 2021 that is
about the web developer salary Trends
let's now have a look on the salary
trends of a web developer web developers
are always in demand since new web
applications are launched and managed
continuously they are generally offered
generous salaries across the globe
salaries also depend on the types of web
Developers for instance full stack
developers are paid more than the
front-end and patent developers the
average salary of a web developer in
India is 3 lakh 86 000 per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the United States is 68
524 US dollars per annum I'm sure you've
all heard the phrases software
development and web development
and I wouldn't be surprised if you use
them interchangeably or even mistook a
software developer for a web developer
well let me break your bubble they are
different today's topic of discussion is
software developer versus web developer
so moving ahead who is a web developer
now a web developer builds and maintains
websites and other web applications he
takes web design and turns it into a
website
web developers are responsible for how a
website or web application looks and
functions from its user interface and
page layout to backend systems for
Gathering data
a web developer is expected to
collaborate with clients stakeholders
and organization leaders to design
unique and engaging websites for
businesses non-profits government
agencies and anyone else who's looking
to communicate more effectively online
so diving a bit deeper a web developer
can specialize in different areas based
on their skill you have the front-end
developers now these are experts who are
in charge of how websites and
applications look and function from the
user's perspective
next there are back-end developers who
focus on the technical aspects of
websites and web applications that
support both basic and advanced
functionality
now they largely work on administrative
components which include databases
website architecture application logic
creating new apis and user interfaces
based on predefined specifications
and lastly there are full stack
developers who are professionals
responsible for the development of an
application from start to finish they
specialize in both front-end and back
end of the application development
typically a web developer should have
good skills in various Frameworks and
markup languages like HTML CSS
JavaScript
react shares angular and database
Management Systems like mongodb and back
in tools like node
so I hope this helps you understand who
a web developer is some of their
responsibilities and their basic skill
set
next up let's understand who a software
developer is
now software developers are responsible
for creating more complex applications
and programs for computers and mobile
devices
they create conceptualize program
document test and upgrade software and
their components
software developers invent manage and
optimize computer programs that run on
desktops laptops smartphones and other
mobile devices
these computer science professionals
write complex code that governs how
desktop applications function
they also specialize in troubleshooting
code bugs updating user interfaces
creating new tools and much more
just like web developers Professionals
in this field are often categorized into
specific roles based on their
specializations
we have the application software
developer and the system software
developer now an application software
engineer is a professional who focuses
on designing specific desktop and mobile
applications tools and games for
Consumer audiences
and the system software developer is
largely concerned with designing systems
level software for Enterprise customers
rather than the public
the software they develop is used to
manage corporate Network apps database
Management systems and other critical
infrastructure
talking about their desirable skills
they need to be proficient in
programming in the field of JavaScript
Java c-sharp PHP Python and Ruby they
must also have a good understanding of
operating systems Network and database
management
so now moving on to the main topic of
discussion software developer versus web
developer
first let's compare the two based on
their prowess or area of expertise
a software developer is associated with
developing products that can be run on
multiple systems
this product could be any kind of
software
their area of work includes requirement
analysis planning coding testing of
applications implementation deployment
and maintenance
talking about web developers they are
responsible for the development of
websites
they're also expected to follow the
process of the software development life
cycle while building their products
next up is the type of product
now a software developer creates
programs for Standalone desktop or
mobile platforms
on the other hand a web developer takes
care of the web framework server-side
functions API integration and the
business logic
the third point of comparison is product
compatibility
now software development applications
are compatible across multiple operating
systems or platforms
the web applications on the other hand
are designed to be compatible across
multiple web browsers
next up is the learning curve well
software engineering never focuses
exclusively on coding
however you should know at least a
couple of languages and a deeper
understanding of how they function
some of the languages that you should be
proficient in include Java c-sharp
Python and some of its libraries and
Frameworks JavaScript and Ruby among
others
a web developer should be familiar with
markup languages like HTML CSS
JavaScript libraries and Frameworks like
react and angular
you should also have a good hold of
back-end Frameworks like python Django
and node
the next parameter is a job title
now there are different job titles for
these professions some of them for
software development are software
developer software engineer Junior
software developer senior software
developer and a software architect on
the other hand a web developer could
receive titles like front-end developer
back-end developer full stack developer
or just a web developer now of course
companies have discretion over assigning
these job roles to their employees
lastly let's look at the job outlook and
salaries
now the job growth projections for
software developers are even more
optimistic than those for web
development roles alongside promising
job growth software developers also have
higher salaries than other it
professionals
now the average salary of a software
developer in the US is around 76 000 US
dollars per annum and the average salary
of a software developer in India is
around 5 lakh Indian rupees per annum
for a web developer the average salary
in the US is around 68 000 US dollars
per annum and in India it's around 4
lakh Indian rupees per annum
now I'm sure you must be confused as to
which one to choose
well to be frank it's just a matter of
preference if you have strong knowledge
of data structures file systems
algorithms Source Control operating and
network systems then software
development would be a better choice
but if you have creative ideas for
websites love designing them have a good
understanding of HTML and CSS and
ultimately The Knack to integrate your
design ideas to create responsive user
interfaces then a web development role
could be a good career path
then web development could be a better
career path to choose today's topic is
web developer versus a web designer now
it is extremely common to get confused
between a web developer and a web
designer now these roles are used
interchangeably given their names and
dependency on each other however there
are a few differences among them people
aspiring to get into web development
often ask me which role is suitable for
them or rather where do they fit in or
what has to be done during the process
of web development
so I've particularly kept this session
clear to clarify all your doubts and
provide an insight into both web
developer and web designer roles and
their responsibilities
so let's begin
first let's look at what's in store for
us
we'll first look at what web development
is
then we'll understand who exactly is a
web developer
after that we will have a look at what
web designers actually do
moving ahead will compare between web
developers and designers to give you a
greater insight into both the roles
then we'll look at the current salary
trends of a web developer and a designer
in the tech industry
and lastly we'll conclude with deciding
which role to go for
so without further Ado let's get started
what exactly is web development
so web development is the process of
building websites and applications for
the internet
now keep in mind that web development
and web design is seen as different
fields in most of the use cases even
though they collaborate together to
provide the end result that is the web
application
so the web development can be broken
down into three layers that is the
client-side coding which includes the
front end then you have the server side
coding which is the back end and then
you have the database Technologies
but who exactly is a web developer
now that we know what web development is
let's understand this
so here are some of the Technologies
used by a web developer there's HTML for
web layout
CSS for web styling JavaScript for
making web applications more responsive
and Interactive there's reactors which
is a JavaScript framework used for
front-end development
and then there's node.js which is a
JavaScript framework again used for
server-side development
there's mongodb which is a database
technology for storing data for web
applications
and then there's also angular which is
another front-end development framework
based on typescript
now there are many other Technologies
like PHP Java Ruby Etc
and these are most commonly used by all
the web developers but you might be
wondering who a web developer is now the
role of a web developer is to build and
maintain websites
he also takes a web design which has
been created by either a client or a
design team and turns it into a website
now web developers are also responsible
for building a product that meets both
the clients needs and those of the
customers and the end users
web developers collaborate with
stakeholders clients and designers in
order to understand the vision
a web developer also has to perform
specific tasks
however these responsibilities may vary
depending on whether they're working as
a front-end backend or a full stack
developer generally full stack
developers specialize in both the front
end and the back end
so let's go ahead and know more about
each type of web developer in this field
now there are basically three types of
web developers there's a front-end
developers who build and maintain the
client side of an application
then you have the backend developers who
work behind the scenes and manage the
services of a web application
and finally you have full stack
developers who manage the project
workflow and work on the required
features of a web application
now let's look at each role in detail
first up when it comes to front-end
developers we usually code the client
side of a web application while the
backend developers build and maintain
the services needed by a web application
behind the scenes and then you have the
full stack developer whose prowess is in
both front-end and back-end development
now front-end developers convert the
design into a real life application
using HTML JavaScript and CSS
back-end developers on the other hand
ensure that the web applications keep
running smoothly and full star
developers supervise the development and
guide on best practices
front-end developers ensure responsive
and adaptive user interface for your
applications
back-end developers manage services like
API data storage for the web application
and so on
and full stack developers know both the
business requirements and the user
interface requirements
now let's go through the skill set of a
web developer the skills that a web
developer must have are HTML that is the
markup language for building web page
layouts
CSS which is the style sheet for styling
the HTML elements in a website
there's JavaScript which is a scripting
language for bringing web applications
to Life by making them more interactive
and responsive
and he should also know front-end
Frameworks like react angular view that
help in making the client side of
applications look better and speed up
the development
moving on you have the backend developer
skills
this PHP which is the backend language
that helps in maintaining all the work
that happens behind the scenes in a web
application
and then there's python which is a very
popular language used in various
software development Fields it is used
to handle server-side tasks in web
development then there's Java which is
one of the most used languages for
software development and therefore is
also used in backend development by
Developers
and then there's database management so
databases like MySQL and mongodb are
used for storing data for web
applications
now full stack developers have skills
that cover both front-end and back-end
development of a web application
therefore they manage the workflow of a
web application development environment
moving on who exactly is a web designer
now here are some of the Technologies
used by a web designer this Adobe
Photoshop for image editing and web
design
there's Adobe Illustrator for working
with vectors and scalable web elements
sketch for Designing user experience for
web applications
Adobe XT also used for user experience
design of web and mobile applications
Adobe InDesign for marketing campaigns
like banners posters and magazines
there are many other Technologies like
Adobe After Effects blender that are
used by web designers as well but you
might be wondering who exactly is a web
designer so web designer is one who
plans and Designs the layout and other
elements of a website or an application
he performs digital retouching along
with image editing or video editing in
some cases
web designers are responsible for
designing a product that meets both the
client's needs and those of the
customers and end users
he also designs products that are
user-friendly appealing and Visually
effective
the design is preferably modern and also
easy to use at the same time
so let's go ahead and know more about
the design role
some of the popular design roles include
web designers who design websites and
its elements there's ux designers or
researchers who are responsible for the
user experience of a web or a mobile
application
there are multimedia Specialists who
specialize in handling media for web
applications like images and videos
and then you have game designer which is
another role that employs similar tools
as that a web design like Adobe Creative
Cloud
now let's look at each role in detail
a web designer designs the look of
websites and its elements a ux designer
designs and prototypes to look and feel
of web applications and mobile
applications
a multimedia specialist handles media
requirements like editing images videos
Etc then you have the game designer who
designs the props and characters of a
game for various platforms
a web designer typically uses tools like
Adobe Photoshop and Adobe Dreamweaver
a ux designer uses tools like Adobe
Illustrator sketch Adobe XD
a multimedia specialist mainly uses
Adobe Creative Cloud which includes
Photoshop illustrator and after effects
and then the game designer uses tools
like Adobe Illustrator Autodesk software
blender and unity
so let's go through the skill set of a
web designer
the skills that a web designer must have
Adobe Creative Cloud this is the
industry standard software for web and
multimedia design a web designer must
have an imaginative mindset to design
modern web elements a web designer must
also be creative enough to make the app
look visually appealing he must also
have the ability to give attention to
detail for minor features and
improvements in the web or mobile
applications some of the other swap
skills include communication skills
collaborative mindset and patience
so now let's make a detailed comparison
between web developer and a web designer
so to summarize we've put together a
table for you so a web developer builds
web applications using languages like
HTML CSS and JavaScript while a web
designer designs the web applications
using tools like Adobe Photoshop or
sketch
a web developer frequently uses
JavaScript Frameworks for more
streamlined development while a web
designer uses Adobe Creative Cloud for
most of the design needs
a web developer should possess good
coding skills while a web designer
should have good graphic design skills
web developers have to keep themselves
up to date with the latest web
Frameworks and libraries while web
designers have to keep themselves
updated with the latest design Trends
and color palettes
so going ahead let's look at the
industry trends
web developers usually have a trend of
earning more than the web designers
still it depends on how well you perform
in your particular job role so if you
are good in web design you might
actually earn more than a fellow web
developer
so the average salary of a web developer
in India is around 3 lakhs 90 000 rupees
per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the United States is around 68 000
dollars per annum
the average salary of a web designer in
India is around 3 lakh sixty thousand
rupees per annum
while the average salary of a web
designer in the United States is around
53 000 US dollars per annum so moving to
the most important question which one
should you choose
it is really a matter of preference
if you have a creative bent of mind and
enjoy using good looking web and mobile
applications and also enjoy designing
them then I would suggest you go for a
web or ux designer role if you have a
technical background like Java or Python
and you're interested in bringing the
designs to life I would suggest you go
for a web developer role so this brings
us to the end of this full course I hope
it was useful and interesting if you
enjoyed this video please subscribe to
the simple run Channel thank you and
keep learning
foreign